[Music]
me why would you bet on Goliath when we
got bet David gages this world of
entrepreneurs we get no value to ha run
homie look what I become I'm I'm the
one
if you're wondering why the language
stop spinning on my neck please you had
to switch to English you had the
Armenian version on our guest today let
me let me let me properly introduce Our
Guest today uh we learned English in two
different ways she learned it through
Sesame Street I learned it through
Gilligan
island or many Americans call it
Gilligan's Island but I called it Island
right so anyway she is political
commentator media host and journalist
she's the uh main host and a producer on
the online TV show Young Turks uh having
begun her working as a film producer on
the show in 2007 she also appeared on
the television version of the show that
aired on current TV she's a vocal critic
uh of the political establishment uh she
is a just to for some people that are
confused she's not a birthing person
she's a woman just so everybody knows oh
thank God you clarified that and we're
going to have to talk about what the
situation is in California she went she
went in high school somewhere in vanise
I the name it's a school that's no
longer around you're C on Grant so is
Tom so there's some similarities here a
uh a possible controversial figure fiery
will push back uh uh energized smart you
got the whole thing going on so it's an
honor to have you here on the podcast
thank you thank you it's a pleasure to
be here I I enjoy listening to your
podcast it could also get very fiery yes
um yes the last podcast episode that I
listened to actually this morning was a
fiery one where I what's the name of the
guy it was like a financial gentleman
shiff I think is his last name you guys
were a de Peter Shi
that that was Yes W Fun Fun Fun by the
way respects to our good friend Jen
who's been here multiple times and uh
how's he doing he's doing great he
enjoys coming in here he loves that you
know I I think that he and I are similar
and that we like to debate and we like
to share opinions and then end the
conversation knowing that there's no bad
blood so I think he enjoys being able to
come in here and and speak his mind and
you know you guys seem to treat him with
respect even though they were
disagreements so oh we listen last time
we even had lunch at the house together
got a chance to get to know his wife it
was a great
conversation candidate Jank now and he
the Supreme Court irritator oh that's
right we saw the video that he's uh uh
he's running for office I saw that video
uh he sent it to me it's going to be
interesting to see by the way did you
see Arnold yesterday said that uh he
thinks he would make a great president
you know something to do if the laws
change I don't know if he saw Jen's
video or not and maybe that's the
influence maybe I wouldn't be surprised
yeah yeah so Arnold at be a great pres
that's right this was day ago he'd be a
great president his worry is um whether
uh uh Biden or Trump he's worried about
those two candidates obviously you can't
blame him on one side one person can't
walk maybe you can blame him on both
sides for some people but uh he would be
he sounds like he wants to get in there
and compete anyways before we get into
it let me kind of give you some of the
stories we're going to cover today uh
one uh Arkansas governor uh Sarah uh uh
hucke signed an executive order Banning
woke words in the state document I'm
curious to know what you think about it
meta sued by 42 attorneys uh Attorneys
General alleging Facebook Instagram
features are addictive and Target kids
okay Americans Trust in Media plummets
to histor
low worse than last month it's not as if
it's low it keeps going lower how could
it keep plummeting yeah Hillary Clinton
uh uh motivational speaker was
confronted by Heckler over Biden's
warmongering speech sit down uh more in
new poll says Patriots may have to
resort to violence to save us can you
imagine like what it's like right now
say listen bro I don't want to kill you
but can you just stop like I don't want
I don't want to have to imagine like we
have to say military has to use violence
and then you have uh another one here uh
the Supreme Court could soon change the
internet forever here's what you need to
know it has to do with censorship like
you can't delete anything very
interesting The
Great California the the governor that
you love dearly for short Nome has a
surprise meeting with China's leader X
amid warm welcome in Beijing now he
talks about economy but why would you go
there to meet with this guy maybe he
knows he thinks he's already president
he thinks he's already president the
Santa campaign launches Trump accident
tracker okay Democratic lawmaker says
Congress should consider vote to censor
representative Rasheed uh Talib so we'll
see what that's going to look like
Netanyahu got all the warnings says
former head of Israeli military
intelligence V you got a video from Ron
Paul you want to show which we'll show
here in a minute a story came out about
a month ago a leftist this is the
article leftist an a casparian says
California is a [__] show oh new God how
could you I can't believe I'm sit can't
believe them liberal commentator rages
over cost of California's electric car
shift uh Anna kasparan doubles down
after bashing trans inclusive term
birthing person uh as degrading to women
we'll cover that as well head of Hamas
Hezbollah and Islamic Jihad meet uh
queen of Jordan and then we got a couple
other stories Dana White uh when we had
the meeting with him and the budlight
CEO it seemed like he was very friendly
and supportive of what they made the
mistake they made this was about 6 weeks
ago 7even weeks ago with Dana White and
and the budlight and then now the
announcement comes out that budlight
partners with UFC and they're back if
there's a company that could save I
believe budlight it's UFC and it's Dana
White but maybe we can talk about that
too and then a couple other things we
cannot go without the shooting that
happened yesterday 22 dead 16 injured uh
still on the Run within 40 minutes of
the shooting they already had his
background on everything he had done
before that was very quick research
typically doesn't go that quick but they
kind of knew who this guy was way before
it happened it seems like we'll find out
why Hamas a fighter trained in Iran
before October 7th and we got a few
other stories to get into Rob before we
get into all these stories and learning
more about Anna I want to first go to
our sponsor so if you can play this clip
we're going to do it early so we can go
right into the
podcast since 911 the day before 911 and
I've owned stocks bonds mutual funds
real estate crypto gold you name it I've
owned it but the one thing that's very
important part of my portfolio all these
years is gold I love having a percentage
of my network in Gold that I have access
to in case of many different things
that's why we chose to work with our new
sponsor American Harford gold if you
have retirement funds that you cannot
afford to lose American Harford gold
will ship physical gold or silver
directly to your door also if you have
retirement funds that you can't afford
to lose now is the time to call American
Harford gold a precious metal dealer you
can trust they have the finest products
amazing customer service and a buyback
commitment they've earned a five-star
rating from thousands of reviews and an
A+ from the Better Business buau tell
them I sent you and they'll send you up
to $5,000 worth of free silver on your
first order so click on a link in the
description or call
866939 6984 again
6984 fantastic the Link's going to be
below and you have the number Anna
before we get started for the audience
that maybe doesn't know you maybe they
don't follow you know politics they
don't follow stuff closely I know your
story if you don't mind taking a minute
and sharing your background your story
sure um
so I am the daugh daughter of two
Armenian immigrants uh they immigrated
here as refugees uh fleeing Soviet era
Armenia um and so it's funny because I
think a lot of people look at me and
they just see um American Born white
woman uh but I had an interesting
upbringing you know considering where my
parents came from didn't speak any
English as you mentioned earlier until I
started school elementary school and I
remember you know the entrance exam
consisted of an educat basically putting
up these uh cards that had letters on it
didn't recognize any of the letters that
was the first moment I realized there
was an entire language I don't know and
I was like really really hard on myself
about that so I would wake up super
super early in the mornings to watch
Sesame Street that's how I learned
English and then English ended up being
my strong suit being able to speak write
uh I love history and so when I was in
Middle School my mom asked me you know
what do you want to be when you grow up
you know have you thought about it it's
really important for you to be you know
independent career-minded Middle School
in middle school yeah my mom was very
very interested in keeping my mind in
building a career for myself you know so
I told her I wanted to be an actress and
she's like no I'm not going to let you
be an actress that's not going to happen
so she sounds like an Armenian mom
absolutely she's like unless if your
name is Chris unless if your name is
Chris that's a different P that's so fun
so instead she was like um you know you
love watching at that at that time I was
watching ABC's 2020 every Friday night I
was obsessed with it I loved Barbara
Walters I loved the interview she was
doing and so my mom's like what about
what about journalism and the second my
mom said it something clicked in me and
I was like no no that's that's exactly
right that's what I want to do so from
that moment on I really was driven to do
the kind of work I'm doing today um
being able
to share the news with the world but do
it in a look the the environment we live
in is very different from what I thought
it would be from what I thought it was
when I was growing up and so I realized
that the journalism of the past doesn't
really fit in the society we live in
today and there's just this I don't know
this like superficial way in which
Legacy Media Outlets do their jobs there
is a truth out there and I feel like a
lot of times they're so interested in
appearing neutral that they don't give
their readers or their audiences all of
the details of the story they omit
certain things and so when I started
working in the media industry I started
off at CBS Radio which is very much like
traditional news and I was depressed I
was there for about six months before I
realized oh my God the best that I could
ever do in an environment like this is
work my way up to being an anchor and
the anchors would come in like 10
minutes before the broadcast and just
regurgitate what was written for them
and I found that so boring um there was
no mental stimulation involved I just
hated it and one day one of my
colleagues there came up to me and asked
you know are you interested in doing
this temp job for two weeks it's for a
new show called The Young Turks and I
was like The Young Turks what is that
and I asked a bunch of questions about
the name and once I realized what the
show was about I was like all right it's
two weeks I'm going to go to Europe for
a month it's first time I'm traveling
out of the country I could use the money
why not so I go in there and on the very
first day Jen yuger comes in he's like
rushing in he's super late he's got a
bunch of papers in his hands I'm like Oh
my God look at this this guy so so
unprofessional what am I doing here I'm
glad it's only going to be two weeks but
then he sits down and he just starts
railing against the Bush Administration
and their preemptive Warren IR Roa and
remember this this is at a time when the
news wasn't really telling the truth
about what how much of a disaster that
war was how much of a disaster our war
crimes were we were committing war
crimes you know the Bush Administration
was and it just felt so refreshing to
see someone give the audience the facts
about what was happening on the ground
but also just tell the truth about how
much this is going to lead to backlash
toward the United States how
counterproductive this is and I just
really appreciated that so once I saw
how he conducted himself and how he was
telling the audience what the reality
was I didn't want to leave and
eventually um things kind of came to a
head because the company was in Dire
Straits financially speaking uh we were
carried on something called air America
radio that's where the majority of the
revenue was coming from at that time and
so air America had gone bankrupt at this
time I'm working both jobs I'm still at
CBS because that's the stable job I love
love tyt but it's not so stable and it
might go under any minute because of air
America going bankrupt and Jen calls me
into his office I'll never forget this
day I remember it so vividly he just
tells me listen I need you to quit CBS
and I was like oh okay but looks like
tyt is in trouble you guys might go
under like what happens if I quit my
stable job work at tyt and you guys go
bankrupt and he's like well that's life
in the big city and apparently that one
line was persuasive enough for me to
quit my job at CBS sold yeah and it was
the best decision I made I mean it was a
risk at the time I guess if you want to
think of it that way but I realized that
I was so unhappy with what my future
would have been if I stayed at CBS that
I just decided to take that risk and
figure it out from there and look what
you guys have done now K the two of you
guys it's amazing great story thank you
for sharing your story I think it's the
best transition into the story that came
out yesterday Americans Trust in Media
plump
to Historic low okay so this is an axio
Story American Trust and media has
fallen to Historic low according to new
polling from Gallup trust and media has
previously dropped to 32% in 2016 before
rebounding slightly those gains have
essentially been wiped out according to
the poll only 32% of population reports
having a great deal or fair amount of
confidence that the media reports the
news in full fair and accurate way the
other uh the only other time in recent
history that trust had fallen to 32% was
in 2016 in some cases the sentiment is
worse today record high numbers number
of Americans 39% said they don't trust
the media at all that number has
steadily increased since 2018 much of
the sentiment dip is driven by democrats
and independents whose Collective Trust
in Media has plummeted 18 and 13
percentage points respectively from
their 2018 Peaks why do you think that
is well I think that the polarization
that we're experiencing with the
American electorate is reflected in how
the media conducts itself I think
depending on what you're watching you
will get only half of the story um and
then so I think that's definitely true
of some of the more New Media Outlets
independent Outlets they cater to a very
specific portion of the
audience very specific portion of the
electorate and I think Americans are
increasingly realizing okay I might be
in a ideological bubble depending on
what kind of news I'm consuming so you
have that
then on a more corporate level if you
want to put it that way uh corporate
media Legacy
Media I mean they've gotten so many
things wrong over the years and I think
that all of those mistakes add up in
people's minds and it leads to distrust
so I look I'll give you an example that
I think you guys are probably definitely
going to agree with um but then I'll
also talk about it in the context of
some of the stories that I got wrong
because I relied on Legacy Media
so in the leadup to the Muller report if
you were consuming the New York Times
NBC if Legacy Media was what you relied
on for your information you were under
the impression that without question the
meller report will prove that Donald
Trump had colluded there was a big
conspiracy between Donald Trump Vladimir
Putin and
Russia the report did not bear that out
and it was just I just felt like I was
misled by a lot of that reporting I felt
like a sucker for buying that reporting
so that already was like a major hit
when it came to my trust in corporate
Media or Legacy Media then I saw the way
they treated uh Jen yuger when he ran
for congress the lies they told about
him were outrageous and I was like oh my
God I don't know what to believe from
them if they are willing to literally
take an interview he did with David Duke
that was a super heated interview Jen
was not friendly to him I mean they took
a sarcastic comment that Jen made in the
context of that interview and they
reported it as if he was like he wasn't
sarcastic like he meant what he said and
you go back and you watch that interview
you watch that statement and you're like
no it's very obvious he's being
sarcastic here so you start losing trust
as these I don't even want to say
mistakes I feel like in some cases some
reporters have an agenda and their
agenda becomes clear in their
misreporting intentional intentional now
I don't think that's always the case I
don't think that's the case the majority
of the time but when I look at the
stories that I got wrong during the coid
era right and mostly culture War related
stories it's because the media
intentionally and I'm going to say
intentionally omitted incredibly
important details of those various
controversial Stories the Kyle
writtenhouse story perfect example of
that I got that story wrong because I
relied on corporate media and look I I
have to hold myself accountable so I'm
not saying that to place blame or
transfer the blame onto others I should
have done my due diligence and I should
have gone out of my way to read from
reporters that might have a different
perspective I didn't do that and now
I've learn to really go out of my way to
understand the arguments made on all
sides but if you are relying on one new
source or if you are under the
impression that the media Outlets that
have been around forever are the most
credible the most legitimate and the
most accurate you will be misled you
really do have to have a healthy diverse
media diet in order to get a better
grasp on what's happening in the country
and in the world and and you made a
great point and you mentioned it was
like right with the Trump and all that
can you bring that chart back up Rob
notice how in 2016 Donald Trump the
election where's that you you have that
look look at at 2016 Rob look at look at
that drop that Republicans are like we
know that they were lying but look at
how Democrat you're showing this so the
audience knows the red is Republicans
blue is Democrat the dot isend
Independence kind of pack gradually went
down Anna but notice the the Republicans
knew that they were full of crap but
isn't that crazy Democrats were like oh
my God we love the the they're telling
the truth about Trump and everything and
then look at it's still slowly gradually
dropping down to 58% but it's crazy how
that moment in time at the 2016 that
election the Trump and everything
it was like the why when he said fake
news people were like yeah whatever he's
full of crap but look at that and whose
data is this whose report is this who's
the
source I don't know but it's but is this
like an independent survey I know Gallup
just put out survey because Pat my
understanding is if you take out sports
scores in weather this is actually
zero for Democrats no media Trust in
Media if you take out sports scores and
weather it's actually zero oh I see what
you're saying got it you know based on
what you're saying I want to get your
reaction on something can you pull up
the shamat clip can you pull up the
shamat so shamat you know billionaire
former owner to Gold Golden State
Warriors they run a very good podcast
himself David sax and his peers and
shmat when he says things he's not
coming from a sensational emotional he
just kind of says it the way it is he's
not a trump guy he didn't vote for Trump
he voted for Biden he voted for Hillary
and then he just recently said this I
think last week go for it when Trump was
elected I was told that it was the end
of the world and that's what I thought
and I'd already underwritten him as an F
okay and then four years into the
presidency he was probably like
uh C in my mind and then as I get a
little bit of distance away I realized
no hold on a second this guy was like a
BB Plus like he was pretty good I voted
for Hillary Clinton I voted for Joe
Biden but this is the honest assessment
the guy did for the things that he was
supposed to do a good job and for where
every other president found a way way to
frankly make our situation a little bit
worse specifically around Wars he did
not do that and that is a huge
accomplishment that I think needs to be
acknowledged I think the thing that was
smart about Trump was that he was
willing to do business yes he was to
negotiate and he didn't feel the need to
make these moral condemnations all the
time he was willing to meet with Kim
Jong on he was willing to meet with
Putin and and cing and he avoided uh
criticizing them personally he didn't
call them dictators he talked about how
smart they are yeah it's the art of the
deal right I mean at the end of the day
he's looking to do business now this is
not a prot trump podcast this right here
with Shaman and those guys they're just
kind of having conversation David Sachs
even did a Twitter spaces the first one
they did they did for Dan santis him and
musk were wanting DeSantis to be the guy
they're not somebody that's want to get
want want to get behind Trump and it
seems to be there's more more players
like shamat who are coming out saying
look man I couldn't stand the guy I
didn't agree with the guy but if I have
to choose between him and Biden dude
what is going on today in the world like
with Iran with Israel with Hamas with
you know Ukraine with Russia with
economy all this stuff what the hell is
going on yeah okay I don't like him but
I would much rather have him than who we
have today what you what is your
reaction to What shamat said my reaction
to that is look you can look at the
policies that he implemented and great
him on that but I think that's entirely
separate from my genuine concerns about
Donald Trump and they're not policy
related at this point um I I do have
some disagreements policy-wise but
putting that aside look I think it's
really important to protect our liberal
democracy and you know what I mean by
that right when I say liberal democracy
I'm not referring to Liberal Democrats I
totally get it I totally get it I
separation of
powers voting like like a democratic
process I am
concerned especially following you know
what happened with the fake electors and
all of that right I am concerned that
Donald Trump doesn't value our liberal
democracy and he has said as such I mean
in a fairly recent rally he talked about
you know solidifying and
increasing power at the executive branch
which is by the way very similar to what
led to mass protests against BB
Netanyahu and Israel he wanted to
essentially disempower the Judiciary in
that country and the Israelis stood up
to that because they realized that it is
a gross violation of their liberal
democracy and so that is my biggest
concern with Trump at this point
honestly if I objectively step back and
I look at what people had the biggest
issues in regard to Trump's policies
were right like the biggest issues were
his treatment of migrants but then you
look at the Biden Administration and he
continued a lot of those policies until
a federal judge said no the co era is
over you can't use that as an excuse in
basically preventing Asylum Seekers from
coming into the country so Asylum
Seekers started coming back into the
country as a result of that but Biden
wanted to just continue Trump ER
policies on immigration and the same
Democrats who made Trump out to be the
devil as a result of those
policies totally quiet about Biden
totally quiet okay there's just so many
examples of that double standard that
like now if I if I look at Trump and I
compare him to a a typical corporate
Democrat there are similar there are
differences too I don't want to make it
seem like they're totally the same but
there are similarities and a lot of
those similarities have to do with the
issues that Democratic voters claim to
have a problem with Trump on
so I don't fear Trump policy-wise the
way I did before but I do fear what
would happen to our liberal democracy
under a second Trump term can you unpack
that please I'm worried that he won't
leave I'm worried that he will
disempower other branches of government
in order to increase the power of the
executive branch so to have a third term
fourth ter like that's kind of what
you're thinking I'm worried that he
won't leave after his term is over I am
concerned about that you're worried he
won't yeah how do you implement
something like that because I'm right
there with you I you the whole concept
of this mixed media diet in 2015 2016 I
basically didn't even work that year I
kind of had a nice exit from my company
I just sat around and watched MSNBC all
day I watched Morning Joe every morning
okay straight up but you know we were
fed this bowl of lies and and like most
Americans who are watching traditional
mainstream media I fell for it you got
me and just like the Muller report if
we've seen the Durham report come out
recently it's kind of like yeah we yeah
they get they got us but most people I I
think double down on what they believe
there's confirmation bi us they're not
willing to say like you said hold
themselves accountable be like yep I got
it wrong yeah yep I got it wrong
especially journalists most journalists
these days you talked about where
journalism was and like sort of like the
um the journalism of the past most
journalists these days are essentially
activists right whether you're on Fox
News you're your Hannity you're you're
you're you're aligned with Trump whether
you're on CNN and you're Don Lemon
whatever you're literally crying when
Trump is out of office so this mixed
media diet so it's it's almost like for
you personally you're almost like a
woman without a home it seems or maybe
even a birthing person without a home at
thank you Adam thank you want to be
clear here where do you go from here
doesn't sound like you're a trump fan
doesn't sound like you have any love for
Biden or even a Nome candidacy where do
you go from here where do you absorbed
your media diet like unpack all that for
me and and to be clear
Trump like how do you come up to the
assumption that he's just never going to
leave office how does that happen it's
not an assumption it's just based on his
past Behavior you know it's totally
based on his past behavior and his like
unwillingness to accept the election
results and by the way I mean I'm not a
fan of Joe Biden I and I live in
California so obviously it's a deeply
Blue State the state was going to go for
Biden anyway so I didn't vote for Biden
I wrote in someone else I voted in
Bernie Sanders because I wasn't a fan of
Biden I continue to have issues with him
although there are some areas where he
has done better than I expected let's
just put it that way Biden has yeah I
mean there are definitely like policy
areas where you guys might not agree and
you guys might might not like what he's
done but you know he has I'll give you a
perfect example there were because of
the Trump era tax cuts for corporations
and the wealthy there were certain
companies like Amazon for instance that
got away with paying nothing in federal
taxes and in fact fact would get like a
tax refund from the federal government
which is absurd obviously Amazon is an
incredibly profitable successful company
what Biden has done is he has
implemented a minimum 15% corporate tax
which I think is fair if I'm paying a
significant portion of my earnings to
the federal government and I'm nowhere
near as wealthy as some of these
corporations or profitable as some of
these corporations they should pay they
should pay something and so 15% it's not
the effective uh sorry it's not the
actual corporate tax rate which should
be
21% Trump said that he was going to
close all those corporate tax loopholes
while cutting the corporate tax rate he
cut the corporate tax rate but did not
get rid of those corporate loopholes and
so that allowed for some of the most
profitable corporations in the company
to get away with paying virtually
nothing in federal taxes so Biden
corrected that that wrong in my opinion
and so I support that um he's done other
things not nearly enough to help working
Americans but he's done more than I've
seen from other Democratic
administrations including the Obama
Administration which did not do nearly
enough to help Americans following the
2008 economic crash I want to ask you
follow up on this so okay so let's go
back to your concern which is he's not
going to go away okay some will say
Obama's not gone away okay some
Republicans will say Obama is still
around and Obama's running uh aside from
trying to do stuff what he's doing with
his chef but you know he's still around
you know with uh uh Biden you know
encourage him to do that now that that
could be right that could be wrong and
you can debate it but no one knows 100%
both sides are going to kind of be like
you know no way Obama's living his life
and this whole concept about Michelle
running again it's never going to happen
fine it's a good topic that we can
debate and for you to say I think he's
not going to go away I actually don't
know if I disagree that he's not going
to go away but I think the way he's not
going to go away is like a founder of a
company is so concerned
about the policies that he put in place
that he doesn't want the people that
come after him to eliminate those
policies like do I think Bush cares I
don't really think Bush cares like
listen I'm done leave me alone I'm gone
I don't want to come and say stuff let
me just go do my own thing right do I
think Hillary cares yes do I think Bill
Clinton cared I really don't think Bill
Clinton cared I think Bill Clinton's
like let me go do whatever I'm doing
right I think Obama cares and I think
Trump cares both of them they they're
both Legacy people which is like hey you
cannot undermine my legacy is it a valid
enough of a concern to be that worried
about it I don't know the the part I
would bring back to you is the following
it's been very interesting seeing how
you're reacting to strange things and
communities targeting you for example
MH uh you know Anna kasarian doubles
down after this is earlier this is like
six months ago after bashing trans
inclusive term birthing person as
degrading to women okay now somebody's
going to be like well wait a minute Anna
would never why would is this is this
the same Anna from Young that's not
possible that can't be this is a mistake
this is a fake story right she would
never debate birthing person she should
be okay with that but no Progressive
media host anak asperion stood firm in
her criticism of the term birthing
person as degrading to women she
responded to backlash with humor stating
laughing out loud the meltdowns over
wanting to be referred to as a women
rather than a birthing person is pretty
wild and emphasized her refusal to
apologize saying I'll never apologize
for that especially as a biological
woman who has had the effing lifetime of
being told I'm less than some
Progressive criticized kasparan for her
stance comparing her to JK Rowling and
accusing her of bigotry transgender
activists clarified that the term
birthing person was not used to describe
individual women but rather to include
trans men and non-binary people in
discussion s about pregnancy so I listen
to this I'm like okay if a person
doesn't know you but they know of you
and you're with Young Turks typical
criticism in my Armenian Community
Circle I just kind of you know it's not
like you don't know it how could she
work with the guy that said such and
such about Armenian Genocide okay cool
I've heard that a million times she's a
socialist Bernie Sanders da okay she's a
trump you know what's the TDS whatever
the syndrome she's part she's this she's
that okay that's the that's the
criticism when you know friends are
talking I okay cool but then this kind
of brings it out to like no she is
actually not wanting to be bullied and
categorized and corner to have to agree
with everything that's taking place so
you're almost experiencing a little bit
of what Trump experienced as an
individual that they're now attacking
you and you've been for some of these
guys but now they're coming after you so
do you kind of see yourself saying look
I I don't know if I'm either it's I'm
not the Anna of who I was 5 years ago 10
years ago maybe I'm also maturing with
some of my policies maybe or growing
with some of my policies or no I'm not
the Democrat of 3 years ago or socialist
of 5 years ago I'm I'm also evolving
today what's going on with your
transition well hold that thought for a
second because I'm going to answer that
question but before I do I I want to
address one other thing um which is how
much of a badass I am okay and the
reason why I say that is
because I
single-handedly persuaded the most
well-known known Turkish American Jen
yuger to on his show multiple times
acknowledge the Armenian Genocide I did
that okay I could have just given him
the middle finger and said you're a Turk
I don't work for Turks I'm an Armenian
and I could have just demonized him for
what he wrote when he was literally in
college he was a dumb college student
who had a lifetime of Turkish propaganda
in his head about the Armenian Genocide
and I decided no I'm going to stay here
and I'm going to pursu Ade him of what
the actual truth is and I did that and I
give myself a lot of credit no one else
does Armenians don't but I'm going to
give myself credit because persuading
people doing the hard work of persuading
people that takes effort that takes
strength and we don't have a lot of that
in America right now we have a lot of
crying and whining about people not
agreeing with each other and then
everyone goes off in their own Corner
everyone takes their ball and they go
home okay so to answer your question you
are correct I I do not like to be
bullied or pressured into saying things
or believing things that I do not
believe I find that
terminology
degrading okay that personally because
I'm not a birthing person okay I'm a
woman what's wrong with being called an
a birthing person well first of all um
not all women even have the capacity to
get pregnant so it's degrading to them
to be essentially to have their their
Womanhood questioned if like they're not
what a point unable if they're unable to
have uh kids to begin with but also I
mean look this is this is the thing that
annoys me about this entire issue in
conversation because they'll turn around
and they'll say no one's calling you a
birthing person okay um does someone
need to call an individual who finds the
n-word offensive the n-word in order for
him or her to find it offensive or
degrading you get what I'm saying no one
needs to be called that word to find it
problematic or to have an issue with it
and besides which I was called that okay
yes in a medical setting but this is a
doctor who knows I'm a biological woman
call me a woman but I had a conversation
with that doctor why did you feel the
need to call me a birthing person like
where did that come from and in
California medical providers are
basically like told that there will be
penalties if they don't use the proper
terminology or if they're caught doing
anything discriminatory uh toward the
trans Community now if they're actually
doing something discriminatory toward
the trans Community I think medical
providers absolutely should face
consequences but the idea that we should
change all of our terminology even
toward women who want to be called women
in order to be inclusive is ridiculous
to me now if a transgender person wants
to be called that fantastic I respect it
I'll do it I'll engage in it but I think
in the context of my relationship with
my doctors I want to be called a woman
it's not that difficult it is my
personal preference okay that doesn't
mean that I in any way believe that
transgender people should be treated
differently or that they should be
discriminated against or that they
should not live lives of dignity I have
had an entire career defending them
supporting them and this one issue led
to ridiculous outrage among a fringe
component of that Community they are not
representing resentative of the entire
transgender community and for that
Fringe component if they think that
they're going to shut me up and force me
to say things I don't believe they've
got another thing coming okay I'm going
to say what I think every every single
time do you think they're crossing the
line a little bit and it's getting a
little bit too ridiculous in certain
sexs of okay yeah and who they turn
people off with it and and again it is a
fringe component of the transgender
community and they don't even realize
how counterproductive they're being and
and who's allowed for that to happen
who's who's been a part of that becoming
a reality who do you think look I think
most people want to do the right thing
okay and so they want to be as accepting
and tolerant and inclusive as possible
and they don't want to come across as
being in any way
discriminatory and I respect that I
think that it comes from a good place
but they shut their brains off sometimes
and just go along with things without
considering maybe some of the unexpected
consequences how others might feel about
what they're engaging in I think that
there's this
conflation um with the gay community and
the transgender Community because think
about it like I think a lot of people on
the on the
left think of the trans Community the
same way they thought of the gay
community right like yeah why not
legalize gay marriage like what's wrong
with that who's it hurting but when it
comes to some transgender
issues there is a lot on the line
right like when we do talk about kids
transitioning you want to make sure that
we have a system in place where there's
a proper protocol implemented to ensure
that we're not transitioning kids who
might not actually be transgender you
think it's okay to transition kids under
the age of 18 even if the parents
consent what do you mean medically
medically Anna you seem very smart to me
and I think you have Common Sense yeah I
do have common sense I I think it's a
very difficult question to answer okay I
think that it is a problem when certain
States completely ban it because there
are instances of let's say teenagers who
identify as transgender they're
legitimately
transgender and I don't want to cause
harm to those people right I think it's
a really it's a decision that's left
that should be left between the parents
and the
doctors but at the same time there are
certain things going on where I do worry
like have I don't know if you guys have
read about the Tavistock clinic in the
UK that's shut down and the reason why
it's shut down is because it just became
this system of transitioning miners
without really doing the proper
protocols to ensure that they're you
know they're working with people who are
legitimately transgender okay so you're
14 years old I don't know if you said 14
or 13 years old when your mom tells you
what do you want to be you said I want
to go be an actress and she's not going
to be a patat right and you said I'm
going to go be a Barbara Walters why
don't you go be a journalist that's
exactly what I want to do and I go okay
what if your mom doesn't say that to you
what if your mom doesn't put that in
your head what if you go into Hollywood
maybe your life's going to be different
story today I don't know what it's going
to be good bad or ugly but it's going to
be a different life that's probably what
but what I'm saying it's it's going to
be a very different life I actually
think you would because you have drive
but it's going to be a different life no
matter what direction you would have
gone to but the point I want to make is
with this whole concept of even
entertaining the thought of it being
okay before the age of 18 you know then
then that means like my idea I have a
controversial idea I would rather have a
15-year-old kid that has a job paying
taxes vote than a 28- year old person
who's never had a job never paid taxes
that person shouldn't vote so you're out
of your mind I get it it's it's not a
you know normal idea that I'm proposing
you have the right to say you're out of
your mind but my what what my idea is I
want to give people the right to vote
who earned the right to vote who have
contributed to society minus those who
have disabilities things like that
that's not what I'm talking about or
elderly all I'm talking about is a 15y
old person should have the right to vote
who is paying taxes has a W2 job has
paid $3,000 of taxes whatever versus 28
who hasn't but this concept of saying
yeah I think my son told me you know
he's a girl you know and he we have to
do this and da and they're crying
getting emotional I think we have to
be a little less tolerant to stupidity
and insanity if you're 19 years old and
you say like my kids will say that my
son is having this tattoo conversation
with me here we go and you know which
son it is he's like hey but you know
such and such as tattoos I said but
Michael Jordan didn't have tattoos said
that's a good point I said Brady doesn't
have tattoos by the way I hope these
guys don't have tattoos in weird places
all I know is I don't I've never
seen Michael could have a tattoo of goat
somewhere never going to see but but all
I'm saying is these guys are like what
about this and what if I want to get it
I'm like dude let me just put it to you
this way when you're 18 you can get it
till then I'm not going to support you
getting a tattoo after that do your
thing my goal is to try to encourage you
and as much as I can to one day not do
this right right I mean but that's your
parental right okay so I think that I
get
uncomfortable getting in between
a parent their child and their doctor
right I actually do believe in parental
rights and so I do have an issue with
some of these schools uh and school
districts promoting policies of keeping
parents in the dark when it comes to
their child transitioning that's in the
state of California yes and the reason
why I say that understand look I think
that like in the State of Florida in the
legislation that they passed there are
exceptions for
kids who might like if there's reason to
believe that their parents are going to
be abusive if they're informed of this
right there is a carve out in the
legislation in Florida to ensure that
the teachers have the ability to
withhold that information from an
abusive parent or abusive parents I
think that's important because there are
cases of parents who are abusive and
might be awful to their kids might maybe
beat them might disown them if they find
out their trans so that's why I think it
is important to have protections for
those kids however at the same
time we've all acknowledged that the
suicide rates among transgender people
are high and if I had a child who
started identifying as transgender and I
was not informed about it I would lose
my mind because I would be concerned
that I'm not there to help with my
child's mental health but those are two
different things so I I want you to go
okay so are you saying
that a parent should have the right to
allow their kids to
transition uh and change their sex
you're saying that should be the parents
consent yes but I do think that there
should be protocols in place and
safeguards in place in the medical
industry let's go one step for yeah and
by the way let me be clear so when we
talk about medical transition I'm not
talking about surgeries I'm talking
surgery and taking hormones and stuff
like that no no okay
so puberty blockers I think should not
be like out
okay pubert there so there's puberty
blockers and then there are the cross-
seex hormones pre8 puberty blockers
you're okay with I think in in instances
where there is a proper protocol in
place to ensure come on but science let
me wrap up we haven't seen what the
outcome of these 20 it hasn't been 20
years to see how much these kids are
going to have suicide I think at 14
years old I get what you're saying the
parent It's Pat it's your kids I don't I
would never get involved I could give a
suggestion but to Al a
child's biological makeup in the long
run I just don't here's a question the
thing with puberty blockers is it
depends on how long they're taking it
right if they're taking it for a long
period of time there are possible side
effects that are damaging and it it
would cause irreparable harm so I
understand where you're coming from when
it comes to the surgeries though I'm
entirely against the surger so that's
good so let's so that's good that we
have one step but I want I want to ask
you this question so you're Armenian I'm
Armenian there's another legendary
Armenian out there called Jack Kor Koran
I don't know if you know who Jack Koran
was Dr Death Dr suicide right he was
Armenia legendary right they made a
movie about him I think Pacino play or
dairo play Pino play yeah
so this guy you know hey life is hard
you want to commit suicide I'll do it
for you don't worry about it life is
very hard so what if we get to a
situation where Mom and Dad consent son
comes daughter comes saying life is is
so freaking hard I can't do it I want
you to take me to the modern day Jack of
Orin okay and I want to I want to I want
you to take my life away and Mom and Dad
pray on it and they say look if that's
what our kid wants let's go take them
and I mean look obviously I'd be against
that because where maybe if I explain
where I'm coming from you can understand
my my thoughts on this
right I want to implement policies that
cause the least harm to people right
transgender teenagers exist and suicide
rates among transgender people
especially if they're not able to feel
comfortable in their own bodies right
that that suicide rate is real and so
how do we balance okay the concerns
of potentially causing damage to kids
who aren't actually transgender because
that exists right they're D
transitioners and and I my heart breaks
for them because they've they were on
puberty block blockers for a long period
of time it did cause harm to their
bodies irreparable harm and so I feel
bad for them and I want to minimize the
instances of that happening as much as
humanly possible at the same time for
teenagers who legitimately are
transgender I don't want to cause harm
to them by entirely Banning a medical
process that could be beneficial to them
my point is I don't believe that it is
up to me to decide I don't believe it's
up to anyone in this room to decide what
the right course of action is for them I
think it's up to the parents the doctors
and you know the the individual in
question themselves I have a question
it's sort of a macro conversation are
you leaving this topic no I'm not
leaving this topic whatsoever I'm
actually staying right here by the way
shout out to Dr kavor and all the work
that he's done with the youth in Asia
that's buha with that's been going on
with that um with youth in Asia but to
me and I want to stay here this isn't a
pivot this is such a ridiculous
distraction what do I mean okay there's
so much going on in the world okay we're
we're at $33 trillion in debt we got
runaway inflation interest rates are to
the roof people can barely make their
car payments mortgages everything that's
going on there foreclosures we're on the
verge of a regional conflict that can go
to World War III and in America today
we're debating what the [__] is a woman
what is happening in American society
that we're even having this long
elongated discussion where it's pointed
and it's very like tangible like all
right birthing person woman it's like
the rest of the world is looking at us
in their laughing that that America
can't even get their [__] together this
Beacon of Hope This Beacon of light this
shining city on a hill this this amazing
situation that we have in America and
we're having hourlong debates what is a
woman right China's laughing at us
Russia's laughing at us and here we are
very smart people very informed people
and we're having deep discussions of
whether Anna over here is actually a
woman or not or she's a birthing person
so my question is why are we so
preoccupied of this is this not one big
distraction the culture wor distracting
from the topic uhuh no no I'm not
distracting but you are no you are
asking why this is such a I don't want I
don't want to go to that topic I want to
stay on this topic that's a complete
different topic let us transition away
from this I'm still on this topic the
question we're asking right now is very
important we've gone through trans she's
not for the transition she's for the
medicine pro hormones in some cases then
I bring in korin is that something that
we should allow parents to do if the kid
wants to take their lives because it's
hard she's then saying no then it goes
down to some people from truns are
having true mental issues that they're
going through which is a next thing you
said fair I'm with it but I want to know
why the other day I have this guy at the
uh uh Rob who what's what's our friend's
name that we talked to the plumber
legendary plumber Eric Hecker who's a a
a rathon whistleblower I can't wait for
this to come I'm telling you you will be
entertained the entire time but he said
something very interesting he said you
know what is mental illness and how long
has mental illness been around he says
you realize if you have heart issues we
can show you have heart issues yeah you
can you got a murmur or you got blood
cloth high blood pressure or you got
high blood pressure there is data to say
that he said how do we uh measure
bipolar how do we measure you know
depression how do we measure all and
he's going through all asking all these
questions and he says how do we know
that we don't know that so you go to a
doctor what is actually the test for a
doctor to know that you have bipolar
adh2 what's the test he's just asking
you a few questions what are you dealing
with what are you going there is no test
there is no data they your blood scored
this or you're this so I'm sitting there
listening to this I'm saying first of
all I don't you know okay may
interesting point but then what has this
led to it's led to a multi-
multi-billion dollar product big Pharma
okay so how profitable are these
transitions how profitable are these pu
puberty blocker products by the way I
know you're saying you know why are we
talking about this there's other things
going on in the world for people that
have kids this is a major concern to
them because their kids are being fed
this [__] on a daily basis at public
schools and parents are concerned very
concerned in some markets I'm I'm not
concerned at this point because I've
been talking to my kids about this stuff
very closely and we have certain
resources not everybody has certain
resources to put them in public schools
so for me all I'm going back to is when
you were saying the the depression you
know where people are at if you work
with me like if let's just say I'm
talking about this yesterday Melva or
Nanny 13 years she uses the word poito
with the
kidso like what the hell is this PO I'm
like Mela they're not
poor these kids are not poor don't tell
them they're poor and Jen will say poor
Brooklyn I said babe Brooklyn is not
poor she has a cell phone don't she
doesn't have a cell phone but don't put
that word in her mouth certain words we
use that's the parents responsibility
you allowed those words to become real
and the parent didn't stop it Tom for
you with two daughters you're seeing
this Exchange in this topic told
transition CU I know Adam wants to talk
other topics we're going to get not at
all this is important to discuss what is
what is your uh uh thoughts when you're
hearing Anna and I discuss this well I
have a unique perspective my wife is a
Kur teacher educator she's taught in
public schools La unified public school
as a matter of fact for 10 years and
she's uh taught in private school since
and I have two teenage daughters um and
so I have a house full of portable
reproduction units and
we a second but okay I don't know how
they feel about being calling their if
anybody has a couch I can sleep on for
the next couple days know I got Tom I
got you so but in all seriousness what
is happening in schools is is kind of
dangerous we've gone to a movement of
ratify and separate it is in the the
public schools is ratify what they feel
whatever they feel and then separate
them from parental decisions it is an
intentional it's it's a it's a program
it's what the public schools want at
high school we want to ratify what
you're saying and separate you from your
parents whereas mental health experts
will tell you you want to you know
process and counsel and that involves to
bring the parents in but that's not what
the schools want and so I see it on on
that side
where I can see schools that are
actively and administrations and public
schools that are actively Pat trying to
separate the kids from their parents in
the first place and this is just another
this is another way they do it rather
than processing and counseling through
you know and you don't have to come down
on the kid but it's processing you know
what let's sit down with the counselor
and your parents and let's talk about
this let's get you in a safe place let's
not have your dad turn what you you want
to be what no let's turn down the
temperature in that room and and let's
embrace the child hey what are you
thinking what are you feeling now let's
process it and let's counsel through
because most of the suicides come from
isolation it's the isolation in their
own mind and it's one word it's hopeless
the word hopeless is what is tied to the
majority of the Teen suicides and so how
do they feel hopeless who is around them
helping them feel hopeful trying to
embrace them trying to process trying to
get to the center of where this is well
I've just never had a boyfriend I've
been really depressed sometimes they're
going down bad decision lines it's not a
you know I've always felt this way since
I was 8 years old no they're going down
some decision flows and other things
that are happening socially I just look
the the problem that I have is the
Assumption the assumption that like all
parents are going to freak out and be
super abusive to their kids if they find
out that their child might be
transgender I I just don't think that's
the right
mentality to have I do think that there
are some maybe like religious
fundamentalist parents who could
actually freak out and so again it is
really important to ensure that whatever
policy is implemented that there is
consideration for children or for teens
who might come from a family like that
however no one loves these kids more
than their parents for the most part and
I just know look I don't have my own
kids I have nieces that I'm very very
close with my brother's daughters and
the idea that anyone in our family would
be abusive to these kids if one of them
legitimately like identified as
transgender is ridiculous and I think my
brother and sister-in-law should have
the right as parents to be able to be
there for their daughters if one of them
is going through something like that you
know what I'm saying it's just like this
preemptive notion that the parents are
going to be awful I want you to see that
and remember you can go into these
public schools and it'll be like don't
tell your parents they'll freak out
there is an assumption that's at the
front of it I agree with you 100% I want
you to look at this chart Tom us sex
reassignment surgery Market markets if
you guys are looking for great
investment this is fantastic that's
serious seriously fantastic investment
Micha B over here look at these
procedures and how it's climbing year by
so you're thinking that the the increase
is really driven by the health industry
um oh my God I mean interesting look
think of and by the way I don't think I
I would consider as one of the
possibilities I'm not saying this is it
I'm just I'm a guy that wants to weigh
out and do odds right this is a very
profitable business like when you think
about how much Prozac makes how much
these pharmaceutical companies make and
then so the the business model is this
guys let's make $60 billion and we'll
pay $3 billion in fines in 10 years what
a great business model okay so let's go
make $80 billion and let's set aside 10%
for finds that's going to come back cuz
we're going to screw a lot of people's
lives but we already made 80 billion so
put the 10% in a lawsuit that's going to
come in 10 years here's 8 billion guys
very responsible CFO what a great job
you did and we'll call this $8 billion a
marketing expense it's not a marketing
expense it's a future lawsuit that's
going to come that you screwed a lot of
people's lives okay so this this Pharma
thing is not like a hypothetical there's
so many books written on people from Big
Pharma that left the industry were sick
of it and they said this is really
what's going on behind closed doors you
got to kind of pay pention to it by the
way very profitable and typically these
guys if you look at lobbyist which
industry has the biggest lobbyist can
you pull up the biggest industry of
lobbyists biggest industry of lobbyists
there's insurance is going to be up
there but you'll see pharmas up there
there you go look at the number right
there pharmaceutical and health Product
Industry I spent the most lobbying over
the last 24 years I think you and I
maybe on the same page with lobbyists
these guys are going around like getting
massive paychecks making all the money
in the world world and they're imposing
laws what a I'm you what a great point
cuz I was just writing here question
marks why why the push why all this big
Pharma is back just great example
because why is the left all the all the
government pushing it so hard now 52
billion spent on Lobby in the last 24
years that's freaking insane 356 million
was just in 2021 and that push is
working Pat guess one out of four high
school students in America identifies
lgbtq Plus whatever they're adding I
think they're surfing the wave that has
been made by you know the the hyper
liberal left on this I think they're
surfing the wave but they are sure
exploiting it and lobbying to it because
EPS earnings per share is a sexy
mistress follow the money you always say
that to the next story unless if you
have final thought if you got final
thoughts I'll give it to you unless if
we'll go to the next story yeah the
final thing I'll say is I think that
our issue with legalized bribery leads
to a lot of the distrust and and a lot
of
the you know I'm not saying you're
you're engaging in conspiracies but
there there's a lot of conspiratorial
thinking overall in the country right
now and I think it's mostly driven by
the distrust that we have in our
institutions and I think that distrust
really comes from the fact that we don't
really have politicians that are looking
out for us at the moment we have
politicians who are in like they're
literally investing in individual stocks
yeah after getting briefed in closed
door briefings on various issues around
the world and in the country then they
turn around and they trade stocks based
on that information that's insider
trading you have money in politics you
have these corporations you have these
lobbyists patting the pockets or the
coffers I should say of these
politicians yeah so when you see all of
this policy being passed that doesn't
actually benefit ordinary Americans that
leads to the anger that leads to the
distrust and I think it's really at the
heart of a lot of the problems we have
in this country wait you mean to tell me
Anna that Nancy Pelosi didn't make her
$150 Million by luck I don't know I
don't I don't know if you guys know this
but Nancy Pelosi is like a genius when
it comes to the markets weird I mean her
her her husband Paul is predictive
skills
predictive genius let's go let's go to
another genius tried to get her tol Jim
Kramer she wouldn't take the job she's
worth 290 million let's go to another
genius uh Nome here's an article from
the blaze a month ago left his anic
experien try get in trouble you're
trying to California is a [__] show
under Nome yes leftist commentator anak
sparing the youngers describes
California as a [__] show the leadership
of Golden State Cal governor governor
Nome a Democrat California without a
question of shome but I guess propping
up proven failures is what the
Democratic party excels true at these
days kasarian opine in a post on X
failure is what democratic party excels
at uh I'm sorry no Nome who served as
Governor since 2019 one re-election last
year after surviving a govern da d d
okay so California you're still living
in California right I live there for 24
years minus 3 years in the Army you
lived in California you lived in
California I was born there and he's
dated a lot of Californians but he's
never lived in California so how is
California like today how was your
Governor doing today and why are you
still in
California I'm still in California I was
born and raised in Los Angeles I'm not
going to leave and just allow the most
extreme elements of the left destroy the
state okay so I'm going to stay and I'm
going to fight and I'm going to make it
better I think LA and California in
general still has a lot of potential but
there have been some policies
implemented that have been disastrous so
Gavin Nome and the current uh Democratic
legislature in the state of California
have engaged in this trend of
decriminalizing everything and refusing
using to regulate things so I'll give
you some examples one of the things that
they decriminalize but refuse to
regulate is prostitution okay I think
that sex work should be legalized and
regulated okay what I mean by that is I
don't want to see
prostitutes walking around in thongs on
the streets as kids are walking to
school but what the Democrats in
California have done is we're not we
don't have the balls to actually
legalize and reg at it and we're lazy as
hell so we're just going to do the super
lazy thing of
decriminalizing which means we're going
to disempower our legal system
disempower law
enforcement and just allow sex workers
to do what they're currently doing right
now which is they have no protection
they're not paying taxes they're being
controlled and and sex trafficked by
Johns okay it is the worst possible
solution to the issue okay no one is
safe everyone's angry and you see all
sorts of terrible stuff happening right
there in broad daylight in the middle of
the street okay they did the same thing
with drugs okay we're going to
decriminalize so what do you see in
California bunch of people shooting up
okay and smoking crack all over the
place I'm sorry I'm not interested in
seeing that I don't think that we should
be you know dealing with that on the
Metro
System why do taxpayers have to deal
with that so they don't want to they
don't want to do anything to regulate
again I am fine with legalizing these
things as long as we regulate it as long
as we find the right balance to keep
everyone safe keep everyone as happy as
they can be so we can see these cities
Thrive but these cities are not thriving
okay San Francisco is terrifying and I
it's hilarious to me because the
business Community there wants to put
lipstick on a pig they want to put out
this $4 million ad campaign pretending
as though everything in San Francisco is
all hunky dory it's not hunky dory San
Francisco is a nightmare yes violent
crime went down a little bit but your
car is going to get broken into okay
you're going to get robbed those are up
by the way both those two categories are
up and the smash and grabs you left
Smash and grabs in La cuz they
decriminalized under, keep going I mean
it's just not it's not right there are
certain issues that we've had for a long
time the drug war was a failure and so
going back to the drug war I don't think
is going to be effective but you know
what else isn't effective using taxpayer
money funneling it to nonprofits so they
can literally buy crack pipes and hand
them out at Skid Row there's video
evidence of that so anyone on the left
who wants to come at me and pretend like
this is just a right-wing scare
mongering talking point you're full of
crap and you should go online and you
should watch the videos of literal we
spent $13 billion in Los Angeles alone
last year to combat homelessness you
want to know where that money went that
money went to these trash nonprofits who
have a bunch of Executives making half a
million dollars a year you're working
for a nonprofit dealing with
homelessness that's my money that's my
parents money okay that is the
hardworking people of California paying
incredibly high taxes that go to what so
yeah I'm sick of it I'm sick of it and
honestly just experiencing what I've
seen on the ground in California has
made me question a lot about leftwing
Ideology Now what do you think about
your Governor going and spending time
with G this last week I'll read the
story to you I think even even just
happened maybe yesterday yesterday he
was yes so here you go California
governor Nome has surprising meeting
with China's leader X amid warm welcome
in Beijing California governor n m
during a his visit to Beijing
underscores a shift in us China
relations nuis focus on climate
cooperation comes and height heightened
tensions between the two nations would G
expressing hope that the visit would
enhance cooperation between China and
California she stated I hope your visit
will enhance Mutual understanding
between the two sides and play positive
role in expanding cooperation between
China and California and promoting the
healthy and stable development of Sino
us relations during these discussions
nanj addressed the acceleration of
climate progress and combating the
transnational shipping of precursor
precursor chemicals for Sy synthetic
drugs such as fentanyl she hinted at the
possibility of attending the
asia-pacific economic cooperation Summit
in San Francisco and meeting with US
President Joe Biden why do you think
he's in China he's in China because he
already thinks of himself as the
president okay he I have no doubt that
eventually it'll come to a point where
the Democratic party has decided no no
no this is the person you need to vote
for anyone who speaks out against him is
the
enemy I would just just say that his
leadership in
California is good reason to brush him
off for the loser that he really is okay
you're over there in China talking about
fenel right how about you clean up your
own house how about you take a look at
what's happening with the prosecutions
or lack of prosecutions of the drug
traffickers in your state he can't be
bothered to deal with that right he
can't be bothered to deal with the
absolute
degenerate garbage that comes out of his
administration instead he's going to
China pretending as if everything he's
been doing in California is great and
he's a great leader who you know has
that road paved for him to be president
I can't stand Nome okay we're talking
about a guy who has implemented policies
that has increased crime in his State
and then he turns around and says no no
I'm going to sign off on this uh
legislation that bans bulletproof vests
in California
what you're going to ban bulletproof
vests without
addressing the like obvious violent
crime that's happening in your state
that's on tape that's all over the media
he just wants to pretend like what he
has done to the state hasn't actually
happened but it's happened and people
are angry they're Furious about it the
thing that frustrates me is that a lot
of people vote based on Vibes right so
they look at him and they see a a
relatively young guy with good hair and
he carries himself well and they think
that that's a leader but look at his
leadership in the state and then please
come talk to me about how successful
he's been and he's trying to put the
fake on that right now he's trying to
put the head fake uh he vetoed the bill
about uh parents and trans you saw that
weeks ago then he vetoed a bill that was
being pushed by the unions to enforce
fully automated trucks that would go up
and down um I5 that if they were a fully
aut autonomous truck they still had to
have a human sort of driving the truck
and it was it was a jobs Bill basically
and he went against that so he picked a
few things out to really kind of get
this Vibe moving toward the middle and
they chose to promote those things I
think the whole thing is a stage show
and I think the fix is in and I was just
going to say I agree I agree with you
100% he's one of the you know reasons
that we left I know he was he had trying
to get a recall with uh Elder didn't
work out but what I I I can't wrap my
head around why people keep voting for
it's not like it's just him it's just
it's not changing how and you said you
would you're not leaving because you
want to make a change what the hell can
the people that are there do if they
keep voting for the same exact people
same as Chicago same as Baltimore same
as all those horribly ran States why do
they keep voting for these people I just
don't I don't get
it look I I can't speak for other parts
of the country but I think California is
is notorious for voters who aren't
really politically active politically
aware and that has created a vacuum ored
po well when it comes to politics I
would say right and so that's created an
opportunity for some of the
more far-left activist Fringe Of The
Party to basically take control of
things uh and I'm talking about like the
individuals who think that it makes
sense to literally abolish prisons and
police
unbelievable and then they turn around
by the way when I critique it or
criticize it it's like no no but we
don't actually mean abolish no no you
mean abolish Nome has closed two state
prisons during coid he released
everybody tens of thousands of people
from these prisons okay now he lied and
told everyone that the people he
released were all non-violent offenders
all nonviolent offenders they're not all
nonviolent offenders some rapist I'll
give you some ex I'll give you an
example I did deep Research into this
remember reading the story of one of the
people who got uh let out during coid a
woman who literally murdered her
boyfriend and then drove hundreds of
miles north to dump his body she got
released jeez so how are you going to
come to me and tell me no no no the only
people who got released are non-violent
offenders and by the way let's say we
give him that argument right we believe
him they were all nonviolent okay what
did you do after that so you released
tens of thousands of people in one of
the most expensive states in the country
during the coron virus pandemic where a
bunch of where every business is shut
down there's no work what what happened
to them where' they go where did they go
they ended up on the streets probably
super desperate you're you're on the
streets you're super desperate what what
are you going to do recent graduate of
crime College yeah and you nailed it and
there was one there was one guy that got
arrested he was in jail for attempted
murder they released him it was a story
in Cali before I moved there and he
committed murder and he killed somebody
once they released them cuz they were
like we don't want you to get Co in jail
are you are you kidding me to hell with
them they already they sealed their
freaking their
fate just really fast before you ask end
so if you have to get if you have to get
it's all good if you had to guess right
now who's going to run let's say Biden's
not it doesn't look like there's no way
this guy's going to run if you had to
pick two from the Democratic party I'm
I'm assuming uh Nome who would be number
two if you had to guess and we have to
bet money who would you bet who would
run who would who would go who would be
the the Democrats number one you'd say
Gavin Newsome it's going to be Nome 100%
I
either I think Nome is first in line I
think they're also considering people
like uh Gretchen Whitmer the governor of
Michigan oh God help us look I would
take her over it's horrible that we have
to do that I could never vote for Nome I
just not us well here's my question best
of luck if it's a true Open primary
Booker and cloar are coming if it's a
true Open primary AR but I don't think
it's going to be open primary that's why
I say the fix is in yeah when he's going
to China like what has a governor ever
gone Pat to go meet with a a world
leader like that and talk about climate
by the way China has one of the worst
carbon footprints in the world and
they're over there talking about climate
are you freaking kidding me just to be
clear on Newsome best of luck out there
in California you know uh good luck
trying to convince uh Californians to uh
displace their political ideology and
vote independent I think two-thirds of
Californians vote Democrat that's not
changing anytime soon president Nome
there he is he's the man you know they
say the old adage like when you're when
you're running in primaries run to the
left or run to the right depending on
what side of the alley are on and then
pivot to the middle so in California
he's just running in a in in a primary
he he's pandering to the leftist and the
woke mob in California and that's easy
because you're not going to unseat that
guy running to the right we saw what
happened with Larry Elder 5 million
votes still didn't even come close sorry
buddy um but talk about President Nome
as a general election candidate can't go
far woke left that's not going to win in
America so in my opinion you know I
don't think he's that far left I think
he's pandering he's a skilled politician
he's a force to be reckoned with anytime
that you're doing what you're doing over
there showing up on Fox dominating
Hannity doing his thing he's meeting
with she now he's debating Dan santis
whether you like him or not he's a force
to be reckoned with it gen like you you
know danant I'm sorry um Nome very well
what would a president Nome candidacy
look like in a general ele not just
pandering to the left yeah good question
um he would sell out the American people
to corporate interests just like he did
with pg& starting fires and destroying
countless Californians lives as a result
of that he bailed them out he totally
bailed them out he has provided
protection for them even though they
refused absolutely refused to update
their Century year old equipment which
everyone one knew was going to lead to
devastating wildfires that's exactly
what happened the the fire that happened
in um Hawaii same thing there Maui yes
but look what happened in Hawaii is very
similar um but one of the worst fires in
uh California history happened in 2018
it was the campfire was and that
campfire happened because a pg& hook
that was uh holding up the power lines
mhm broke what's PG for all of a Pacific
Gas and Electric yeah Pacific Gas and
Electric the famous Trump uh uh Nome
meet up where they're raking leaves
doing all that stuff okay that worked
out well which by the way like that's
the other thing about that moment with
Trump
so he's not the most eloquent individual
let's just put it that way so when he
talks about raking leaves it's like what
is he talking about here but if he's
volunteering for Park doing can fix it
all the leaves he did
Bey they live right here he did have a
point what I mean by that is you're
supposed to do like the Native Americans
they would do controlled Burns right
they would thin out the forest knowing
that like wildfire season is coming and
it's going to be
unmanageable you have to do controlled
burns the problem is communities don't
like the controlled Burns because the
controlled burns like ruin the air
quality temporarily for a couple like a
couple weeks yeah but you there's really
no other option we're gonna end up
having these wildfires and if you don't
take care of the vegetation it's going
to make it a million times worse so we
had a point there and I the media
overwhelmingly like brushed off that
legitimate what's the larger metaphor
here because 99% of Americans are like
yeah I don't give a [__] about wildfires
but president Nome yeah as a general
elction candidate what does that look
like Beyond what's going on in
California well what we were talking
about earlier right about the
pharmaceutical companies and the
lobbyists and how much influence they
have over our politicians Nome is prime
example is a prime example of someone
who would be overwhelmingly influenced
by corporate interests I know it because
that's exactly what happened with pg& in
the state of California okay they fund
his campaign heavily and he looks out
for them to the detriment of
Californians who literally lost their
homes as a result of PG's gross
incompetence and unwillingness to up
what's the difference between him and
any corporate politician that just gets
bought and sold by the lobbyist there's
not but let's stand this point real
quick let's stand there there's not a
difference um you're where you're going
the answer the short answer is there's
not a difference but let's go to the
circle so people can see it Gavin
Newsome and the green been pushing green
cars green energy and electric cars in
California pushing hard putting uh
percentages out there that are almost
can't be met PG has gone to the
governor's office and saying which do
you want a multi-billion dollar rebuild
of the trans transport lines that go
through the forest or do you want more
kilowatt opportunity out there because
you've got to charge these cars you have
a brown out every time you have a hot
summer what do you think if everybody
plugs in
25% EVS I can't deliver the energy
there's going to be massive brownouts do
you want me to build more capacity or do
you want me to fix all these uh
transport Lines no you're right build
the capacity that's the trade Nome made
the
trade scumbag well I mean we're going to
see if it's going to be happening or not
uh with Nome but next story I want to go
to is what happened yesterday with uh
the the shooting that took place 22 dead
16 injured and still on the Run uh
active shooter uh situation in Maine
Hospital says mass casualty Mass shooter
event this is a Fox news story here uh
let me get to it and I will uh read who
this guy Robert card is so masso
shooting in main has left 22 people dead
and 30 injured two locations main Public
Safety commissioner Micah susuk
highlighted the fluidity of the
situation a press conference emphasizing
The Staggering death uh toll for state
that only had 29 homicides and a fall of
20 in all of 2022 the lon police
department has identified Robert rcard
as a person of interest describing him
as armed and dangerous card as a
Firearms instructor fantastic and a
member of the arm Army Reserve station
in SEO main he had reported recent
mental health issues including threats
to shoot up the National Guard base in
Maine authorities urged residents to
shelter in place and this order was
expanded to include Lisbon uh after
carts vehicle was found near the Lisbon
boat truck and uh who Robert ctis he's a
person is a 40-year-old Army reverse
reservist from uh Balo Maine had a prior
misdemeanor DUI conviction from 27 2007
has shown online support for
conservative figures like Trump Junior
Tucker and denish law enforcement is
actively searching for card who was uh U
last seen driving a white saor uh uh
Outback and a Manhunt has expanded to
surrounding areas after the deadly
shooting at the bar and grill restaurant
and bowling Galley making it the
deadliest shooting the United States
this year Vinnie what do you got on this
story I I just uh I I want to make a
point Pat like obviously within 25
minutes you said 40 earlier within 25
minutes they knew everything about this
one guy and it's just it's just a
coincidence to me every time a story
about Biden comes out yesterday this
happened two or three weeks ago uh we
had another shooting the day information
about Hunter and uh Biden came out was a
big story there was a shooting and all
of a sudden yesterday a story of 40
confidential FBI sources say that
evidence of criminal activity committed
by Joe James and Hunter Biden comes out
this happens and I already know what's
going to happen everybody on the left is
is going to say guns take the guns we
have to get guns but think about this OV
valdi shooter mentally ill El Paso
shooter mentally ill Parkland shooter
Lon Nashville Fort Hood Sandy Hook
Virginia Tech all mental illness and
they say America has a gun problem no no
we have a mental health problem how the
explain to me everybody here explain to
me how the guy has said on on record I
want to go and shoot a bunch of people
in this place the FBI at my old base my
place of work yeah exactly and yeah on a
milit base and the FBI it's like it's
almost as if the
FBI constantly drops the ball cuz they
have so much other things going on like
going after parents at school board
meetings for protecting kids to going
after people at January 6th that weren't
even there W flag how many times are we
going to hear the ball dropped or we had
this guy under investigation and talk
about the mental health issue of this
guy from the friends to the family to
the FBI to mental health it's in here
Pat that just comes out of nowhere
nobody just wakes up one morning and
goes I'm going to go and start shooting
UH 60 people just doesn't make sense
that's the macro and there's a hell of a
lot to unpack in their Vinnie I think
you're on on it but the on the micro I
look at is we keep talking about two
things so he was in a mental health
facility for 2 weeks so after making a
threat he was
appropriately you know uh placed in the
facility and he's there for two weeks
wait I thought we had the um the
whistleblower law I think my brother my
brother has guns and I think he's really
loose right now I think there's some
real problems going on I think someone
should go over there and guess what the
authorities go over to the house and
they take the weapons they say okay you
have a no no sorry you can't have these
you got to give these how did he have
the weapons is that a federal law or is
that a state law I think it really
depends right cuz I don't think we have
a federal law like that no it's not it's
it's not federal we haven't got through
two-thirds on that right so so the
reason why I bring that up is because
each state has I mean it's ridiculous
each state has its own gun laws and so
some states have implemented red flag
laws I don't know if Maine is one of
them obviously the story broke last
night we don't know like a lot of
details I don't know yet um I look I
agree that there is a mental health
crisis and clearly this is a guy who's
an army
reservist um had he not had that stint
in a mental health facility you know he
would legally be able to buy any gun he
wants there's no problem right and even
even the laws that the left um are
proposing when it comes to mass
shootings wouldn't impact this guy he
would totally be able to buy the guns
legally so I think that when it comes to
gun violence in the country both sides
are right it's just that we're all
talking past each other I do think there
needs to be appropriate funding of
mental health in the country the problem
is every time there's a mass shooting
Republican lawmakers point to the mental
health issue
but then when push comes to shove and
they have an opportunity to vote on
legislation that appropriates the
necessary resources for mental health
care all of them vote no the last time
that legislation came up only one
Republican voted yes so there's that
issue I do think look I'm I'm a Believer
in the Second Amendment I've never I
have never supported you know banning
guns but as I've gotten older and now
living in California in the state that
it's in I do believe in having a firearm
for self- protection for defense and I
totally get where gun Advocates are
coming from when they feel that they are
being punished with gun legislation when
a bad guy you know carries out a mass
shooting or a crime with a gun I I don't
think that law abiding citizens should
be punished which is why I think there
are certain regulations that I think
don't punish law abiding gun owners
while also making it difficult
increasingly difficult for criminals to
get their hands on guns so closing gun
show loopholes for instance um closing
loopholes where you wouldn't need to go
through a background check like uh
buying a gun from a private seller for
instance I think closing those loopholes
makes sense going through a background
check ain't a big deal right um but at
the same time just doing that alone I
don't think is going to solve this
problem I think that you're right I
think that there is a mental health
crisis in the country and we absolutely
need to be serious about combating it
yeah this is a this is the the biggest
problem in my estimation is that we're
so desensitized to this thing this this
alert came on my phone yesterday at 1
p.m. at night there you am going through
the stories about we're going to be
discussing today Israel Hamas the
economy oh another mass shooting all
right cool all right what else is out
there that's where we're at in America
today is that it's just another you know
headline the news and will'll be
forgotten about here's the difference I
think this time this happened in Maine
what's the city in Maine that this
happened
in um BN Maine have you okay so that is
an hour away from where New Hampshire
the first primary of the election season
is getting a few months away in February
we're what November December January
three four months away this is in their
backyard we all remember what happened
in Parkland Orlando here in Florida
where this became a massive culture War
over here the the guns schools this that
like this basically took over the State
of Florida I'm wondering how that's
going to have an effect on new Hampshire
in the primaries because then you have
someone like Biden who's coming out
basically saying he's not even in the
primary he's just going to wait till the
general election he's not even he's not
participating but we have RFK who's
basically making noise he's basically
we're seeing that it's the the most
obvious call is going to be October of
2024 it's neck and neck Biden and Trump
that's we've seen it every single time
what what what what role will RFK play
in this especially when it comes to the
gun violence issue in America because he
said very poignantly look I've lost my
father and my uncle President JFK to gun
violence so if there's anybody that can
speak on this topic it's going to be RFK
so it's going to America's desensitized
but we'll see how it basically plays out
in the actual political Arena especially
in New Hampshire with the first
primaries occurring I mean there there's
a legacy that America has to kind of
look at and if the informed voter wants
to look at it we can do it and Rob you
know the one I'm coming to here Daniel
Patrick Mahan you know there is some
common sense here about closing the Gun
Show loophole and when everybody SS
about that in Second Amendment what they
fail to notice if two private people
sell a car a motorcycle a boat or a jet
ski there's a form you have to fill out
and you have to take it downtown because
there's license plates on that because
there needs to be insurance on that so
it seems pretty reasonable that you know
whoever owns what serial number that
just like when you bought the gun the
first time that serial number gets it
transferred to somebody else um so I
think there's some common sense things
on this going to the mental health side
you know you're right they go you know
the right goes to mental health the left
goes to gun control sure but if we could
take a look here not that one the second
one and the paragraph Daniel Patrick
Monahan Under the Kennedy administration
signed legislation that basically the
federal there was a network of federally
funded um mental health institutions in
this country because we recognize people
were having challenges and Daniel
Patrick mon and um there is a pen that
sits in a frame in our capital in one of
the committee rooms that he and Kennedy
used to sign the legislation but to Pat
Monahan he looked back a rare politician
to look back and say we made a mistake
here read this to Chairman Monahan the
pen is no souvenir he believes it
legislation to close mental health
institutions set in motion a national
trategy the asylums emptied out but the
government never built the community
centers that were supposed to be in
place by 1980 it stopped at a wolle 482
as a result the deinstitutionalized
mentally ill mentally ill people with
real challenges released were literally
left out in the cold they were free all
right Monahan said they might hence for
sleep in doorways as they often chose
the problem of homelessness appeared
characteristically defined as people who
lacked affordable housing so he was
pointing out that we didn't even want to
talk about it that we had taken mentally
ill people were're in institutions
getting care where they also wouldn't
harm people and suddenly they were out
there and we said we have a homeless
problem and he pointed out that the
start of our homeless problem was really
thousands and thousands and thousands in
the major cities of midle and this never
got corrected the government never did
what they said they were going to do
which was a starting point of 2,000
community centers to care for the
mentally ill so they don't do wild whack
things like mass shootings did they find
this guy yet no he caught no hell no
he's out in about and he's an Army
Reserve and a Firearms instructor he has
military train you did some research
have we have any evidence of anyone else
that's done these mass shootings of
being a Firearms instructor I don't
think there was one that was an
instructor I remember there was a guy in
California Chris Domer he was a cop I
don't know if he was a veteran the bald
black gentleman that was he was walking
up to people and just shooting them and
then he resorted to like a cabin
somewhere he drove up North and then
either they shot him or he committed
suicide yeah Big Bear he went up and hit
Big Bear yeah so with this guy I was
watching um a news report about him
today and the authorities are actually
very concerned with how he should be
yeah I mean how skilled he is with this
Weaponry yeah and so obviously there's a
Manhunt I have no doubt that they're
going to find him uh but you know I I
also understand where the law
enforcement is coming from on this
because they're concerned with how
skilled he is yeah so it's it's a it's a
it's a good it's a valid reason to be
concerned with a guy like this so okay
next story up I was going to add one
thing I don't know if you're going to
transition to this whole war that
potentially could take place because I'm
going to Netanyahu is where I'm going to
okay well the one thing I was going to
say is that of course the leftwing media
right this is the Daily Mail has
basically said he's been on shown online
support of conservative figures like
Donald Trump toer Carlson and dast soua
so obviously they're already like sort
of categorizing right winger right
winger I just think maybe a story if you
want to cover parlays with this is the
um essentially the the call for arms
that's going on in America today the
yeah that's that's a good story we can
get to that yeah so
so where we at uh that's on page for the
Patriots so just something you want me
to read that story yeah go for it okay
so uh there's a new poll out there that
says Patriots may have to resort to
violence to save the United States sort
of look they're labeling him a patriot
I'm assuming I would say I wouldn't say
that no I wouldn't but they're basically
sort of C there's some table Stakes here
Adam I think that's a little jump yeah
all right Tom let me read the story
there guy go ahead um so there's a new
poll that says Patriots may have to
resort to violence to save the United
States okay in a recent survey conducted
by the public religion Research
Institute P rri indicates that 23% of
respondents believe that Patriots may
have to resort to violence to save the
United States making this the first time
this support for political violence has
exceeded 20% okay the PE TR rri has
asked the question in eight separate
surveys since March of 21 that this is
the first time it has peaked above
20% okay so support for political
violence has seen an increase regardless
of political party affiliation among
Republicans surveys 1/3 that's 33% now
believe violence may be necessary that's
up from 28% in 2021 among Democrats 133%
ch's view in 2023 compared to 7% so
that's a good jump that's a jump
dependence have witnessed they rise with
22% considering violence as an option
from 133% I've done some math on this so
real quick if you're on the right if
you're on the right side of this if you
go from 28% to 33% that's an 18% jump
nothing crazy there the shocking thing
is the Democrats have gone from 7 to
133% uh 85% jump right there and then
independence 13 to 22
69% so you know you get you get
categorized oh the right-wing they're
coming for you whatever they're sort of
holding way higher percentage of of
right-wingers who believe we should go
to violence which 33% is terrifying and
don't get me wrong I'm not minimizing
what we're seeing with Independence and
the left that's also terrifying but what
I am noticing is what started off as
mostly right-wing voters uh like this
trend mostly existing in the realm of
right-wing politics now spreading to
other political ideologies in America
and it's just so destructive so
dangerous and really makes no sense
because resort to violence to save the
country how exactly right right like
finish the sentence how exactly is you
carrying out violence going to save the
country in what way if anything it's
going to get a bunch of people who you
know think they're engaging in some you
know worthwhile Civil War they're going
to end up in prison for the rest of
their lives you know their entire lives
their family familes lives will be
destroyed it just makes I think this is
part of this all stems from the
polarization in the country the fact
that we have dehumanized each other and
we're unwilling to see each other for
what we are we are Americans okay
someone on the other side of the aisle
who I disagree with is still my fellow
American and where we work out our
differences is in elections in the
political realm you know I used to kind
of like look down at this
pressure to engage in civility but now I
kind of understand where that thought
process comes from right because if
things devolve to the point where we get
so angry at each other that we think we
need to pick up a firearm and fight each
other in a violent way well it just
destroys the fabric of the country it
destroys the belief and Trust in our
Democratic process and so look I I can't
control other people's behavior I know
that I've personally tried to bring the
temperature
um on our show I look back at some of
the things that I've said you know like
in 2016 I think that's a perfect example
and it just wasn't the right way to go I
let my emotions get the better of me
rather than thinking strategically of
how we can bring the country together
and get America to a better place and
when is violence if ever acceptable
especially when you're defending
yourself okay well I was going to Adam
it said violence towards who or what was
it specified of what we were talking
about cuz it's saying Patriot so I just
want to say really fast patriotism is a
feeling of Love or devotion a sense of
attachment to one's country which I
don't see anything wrong with that and a
patriot is someone who vigorously
supports their country and is prepared
to defend it against enemies or
detractors and and and hear me out can
you blame I when somebody's getting
angry when the real Patriots like I'm I
consider myself a patriot someone that
genuinely loves this country and has
sered for this country just like Pat
like can you really can you really blame
them when when when these Patriots see
their government actively trying to
destroy the country think about this and
just follow me for a second when they
don't feel safe because the government
lets criminals run a mck like you talked
about Cali commit crime no consequences
same government that purposely leaves
the Border wide open fentanyl coming in
killing a 100,000 Americans every year
mass shootings 600 I'm not trying to
soften it but a 100,000 are coming
through this border let alone the 10
million of God knows how many terrorists
are coming in the same government that
labels parents the domestic terrorists
for simply speaking up at their school
board meetings to protect their uh
children from like lgbtq stuff or
sexualization and CRT same government
keeps sending hundreds of billions of
dollars of our tax money you're talking
about your money your parents money all
of our money to foreign countries to
keep getting into into endless Wars and
the same government that constantly lies
to us about everything everything from
the origins of a deadly virus that came
from a lab from a country that we that
hates us that we funded uh to the the
same government that had a role in
assassinating one of our sitting
presidents and I could see I'm not
condoning violence but at what point do
we say As Americans enough is enough
okay and if you're not willing to fight
for it then what we just sit back and we
just have the attitude go ahead and of
of just H whatever leave the Border open
send our money everywhere I want crime I
want this I think it's time I'm not
saying violence towards each other or
whatever but it's like we got to stick
up for our El we have to say something
orse we're losing it
so I have a lot of empathy for where
you're coming from I mean I disagree
with a lot of what you said but I
understand what part what part what part
of what I said about the list of what
you're go it's the same you live in the
same country that's doing honestly it's
the framing right so you're correct in
you I don't know the exact figure but
gun
violence kills way more than just 600
people right so like M no M suicide
story
gun violence yeah but gun violence is a
problem if you're only focused on mass
shootings then it doesn't seem like as
big of a problem as it really is but it
does claim a lot of American lives every
year that's what I mean like the framing
I I differ from from you on framing but
no and I'm empathetic in feeling that
rage though right and I'm also a very
fiery person part of the reason why I
don't have kids is because I feel like
if I did have kids I would get violent
like I'm not I would do love your
honesty though no I would though I would
anyone gets even close to my kid hurts
like a hair on their head I would anyway
let's move
on um anyway but the point that I'm
trying to make is look we all have these
human instincts that are destructive and
don't actually yield the results that we
want violence is a perfect example of
that because you just carry out violence
because you're angry at at all of the
injustices in our system the injustice
that stem from that system but all
that's going to end up happening is
either the police are going to hunt you
down and kill you in a shootout or
you're going to end up in prison for the
rest of your life that doesn't actually
fix any of the problems you bring up the
parents at the school boards right yeah
now look the parents at these School
boards got real active they got real
organized and even though some of what
they're preaching I don't agree with
they managed to get the results that
they wanted in their school districts so
the reason why I bring that up is is
because if cooler heads can Prevail and
you can think strategically about how to
get the policies you want how to get the
politicians you prefer elected into
office that's a much better and
longlasting
effort strategic effort to change the
country in the direction that you want
to change it into but right now we have
all of these like look we have Wann toe
revolutionaries on the left we have
people preaching for civil war on the
right
it is a recipe for disaster and it will
not yield the results that either side
of the political aisle want that's
that's where I'm coming from the
question becomes how do we get here the
question becomes who caused this divide
the question becomes you know is there a
group that wants this to become a
reality is there a group behind closed
doors that's in instigating for this to
become a reality who wins when this
happens what is their Victory is are
they looking at everybody and saying
look at all these fools we fooled all of
them look what they're doing keep them
entertained keep them distracted keep
them fighting each other keep them doing
this what what are they gaining by doing
such a thing there there's a there's a
there's a few things that scares the
hell out of people of
power one of them is uh we've talked
about this many times is when when they
realize that the people realized that
they're more powerful than them that
scares the crap out of men and women in
power power like I'm talking
establishment power
uh and and typically their answer is
when [__] hits the fan and all their
lies are being exposed they want to
start talking about peace and let's get
along and let's do this and let's do
that so I'm I'm with it let's figure out
a way our entire show here is bringing
anybody and everybody in talking we
don't hold anybody I'll have Anthony
Weiner here we'll have uh uh uh the Mr
Zoom whatever you know Jeffrey tug tub
we'll have him we have a guy like Jen
yuger we'll have Jank on we'll have Alex
Jones on we'll have Chris Koma on we'll
have any we'll just sit down and have a
conversation together to see what's what
but for me um yeah I I kind of like
people who want to for example this
whole conversation with uh Netanyahu and
Hamas I made a video last week history
of Hamas Hezbollah and uh Isis and a
little bit of al-Qaeda the level of
commentary I got of people defending you
know what Hezbollah does what they stand
for all of these other things and I said
listen guy this one guy commented who we
had on the podcast I actually like
talking to him Daniel he said so you're
telling me if we identify Hamas
Hezbollah and Isis as terrorist
organization who has terrorized more
people than Americans that's what his
question was back towards what American
Jews have done to others valid question
here's the difference the difference is
when I was in Iran and I lived there for
10 years all I heard was m b m b m b the
level of hate on mainstream media in
Iran towards America was
nonstop the level of hate and that's
death to America Past America to America
and they still say it today 100% by the
way they say it in their in the house in
the in the Congress Parliament it's not
like they say it in the streets the
politicians are saying it so then you
bring it to here I was in the Army here
I was never in a meeting and never in a
training routine where they said death
upon Hezbollah death up we've never said
that in the US Army we've never That's
Country like death death to China death
to Russia that's not the model here so
the model here isn't that so priority if
somebody is Hamas if you're part of
Hamas guess who you should be supportive
of I'm not surprised if you defend Hamas
if you're part of a gang you're from uh
let's just say maras saat trucha and
let's just say Rob is part of a crib
which doesn't make sense but let's just
say he is okay I foresee you defending
MS13 and I see him defending uh uh uh
[__] I defend neither of you okay but
you guys are going to defend your
position I'm not a dummy to say I cannot
believe you're defending M you're MS13
yeah you're of course you're going to
defend that position however as an
American as a patriot who loves America
and this is where I live and I'm
emotionally still a man a boy that was
born in Iran and I would love to see
Iran become a democracy one day where I
can take my kids and go toet so they can
see where father was raised I'd love to
go to gulb Yan the school I went to for
a couple years in Iran Armenian school
I'd love to do that I can't do that
today and take these kids cuz they won't
feel safe of course I want to see
something happen with Iran of course it
bothers me when I see what happens with
Armenia and azaran of course it bothers
me when I see what they're doing to many
historic monuments that ass syrians had
in Iraq of course it it hurts me when I
see that but I'm in America today I'm an
American today I'm an American Patriot
today and as an American Patriot the
priority
of m going the following way number one
is where I live America number one
number two is allies who support America
and we're on the same page with who the
enemy is then comes everybody else and
I'm Unapologetic about this so if we are
going back to listen man I kind of feel
like we need to you know resort to a
little bit more our military being a
little bit tougher and I don't know why
we're trying to make the military more
lgbtq and you know hey Trump's talking
about the other day they're saying hey
we can create more environmentally
friendly weapons and you know Jets and
all this stuff whether there's truth
behind that or not I knowing the weird
world we're living in today I buy into
it 55% that that kind of stuff is being
said no there needs to be the enemy
fearing you and if there's one thing
that's going on today
is no one in the world I believe no one
in the world fears Biden you have to
have fear love liability and love uh
let's set the bottom to aside okay
likeability and love we need fear we
need respect we don't have fear today we
don't have respect today Zer when
there's no fear when there's no respect
Ukraine's going to do Russia's going to
do whatever they're doing to Ukraine you
got Hamas is going to do whatever
they're going to do to Israel Israel to
me is looking for card to say hey give
us the permission to go destroy those
guys of course they're going to have
that position as well let me just read
this to you got a call got all the
warnings says former head of Israeli
military intelligence okay political
okay Netanyahu got all the warnings it's
not like he didn't know it's not like
it's a regular you know person saying
this year no it's the former head of
Israeli military intelligence Amos
yadlin former head of Israeli military
intelligence emphasizes Israel's intent
to destroy Hamas and Gaza comparing them
to neighboring attack attacking country
we refer to Hamas from now on as the
government Hamas Haman in Gaza a
neighboring country that attacked Israel
and we declare war on this country yadin
criticized Netanyahu for not heeding
National Security warnings stating
Netanyahu got all the warnings that this
is uh weakening Israel's defense and
endangering Israel national security
yadan expresses concern about the
potential for hostage situations and
suggest a combination of operational
AIDS and humanitarian negotiations they
may be released through operational
raids much like 1976 Israel raid to
rescue Palestine held hostages at the
airport in UB Uganda even though this is
not uh antib I think the finger should
be pointed at Hamas leader yaha Yahya
sinir Adam see a story like this what do
you think about the fact that former
head of Israel Military Intelligence
says Netanyahu got all the warnings well
look I'm not in the camp that that that
Netanyahu intentionally allowed this to
happen I'm not there whatsoever do I
think that they took their eye out off
the ball cuz they were so hyperfocused
on the judicial form and the power grab
that's been taking place in Israel over
the last few years especially after he
was you know in and out of office yes
but that doesn't mean that he
intentionally wanted the rape murder
killings of over a thousand innocent
civilians I'm not there whatsoever so it
those stories I feel like are very
inflated and conflated and it's just an
easy narrative he's even said after the
War takes place I'll have to H hold
myself accountable for what happened
here and he will be held accountable but
I'm not there it's just an convenient
theory that like yeah of course he
allowed this to happen he looked the
other way was there a standown order
like Charlie Kirk basically mentioned
I'm not there I haven't seen evidence of
that and quite frankly I don't even want
to believe that but he's going to be
held accountable by his own people no
doubt on that you were Adam you were you
were just recently there I was there in
June be honest with me how was the
security like level I being I had no
idea like how how beefed up were they
well it starts at the airport when
you're flying to Israel okay so you know
even at the Miami Airport like I had to
say to my my mom is like the friendliest
person ever and she hasn't been there in
30 years and she wants to talk Hebrew
with people I'm like Mom don't talk to
the lady at the airport she's not your
friend I love you she's like oh I'm
going back and the lady's like what is
what is your business here what are you
doing like I'm like Mom stop talking to
this L don't talk to anybody the point
is this there's security
that's Miami Miami you get there oh it's
it's unbelievable security security
security security no doubt so my
question to you is as being there that's
why I'm happy to bring this up I
understand that you don't want to kind
of believe it which I wouldn't either
honestly Adam you're a Jewish dude
explain to me how with all the security
that you saw it took 6 hours think about
that 6 hours for them to even respond
these these terrorists were grabbing
people and dragging them to Gaza so with
the security that you're telling me that
at that level it's unbelievable to me to
say that they just what all the IDF all
the soldiers everybody stopped down
which goes to my point P I showed you
this video before we walked in Ron Paul
in 2009 in the Congress on on the floor
in Congress I let I'll let them play
this he is saying that Israel basically
created Hamas to fight yaser Arafat and
then we had a kind of a plan I'll let
Rob Play Robin and Pat we can stop one
over what what minute does it it's going
to go up to a minute this is a
two-minute thing what's happening in the
Middle East in particular with Gaza
right now we have some moral
responsibility for both sides uh in a
way because we provide help and funding
uh for both Arab Nations and Israel and
uh so we definitely have a moral
responsibility and especially now today
the weapons being used to uh kill so
many Palestinians are American weapons
and American Funds es essentially are
being used for this but there's a
political liability which I think is
something that we fail to look at
because too often there's so much
blowback from our intervention in areas
that we should be involved Ines you know
Hamas if you look at the history you'll
find out that Hamas was encouraged and
really started by Israel because they
wanted Hamas to counteract yaser Arafat
he said yeah that was better then and
served his purpose but we didn't want
Hamas to do this so then we as Americans
say well we have such a good system
we're going to impose this on the world
we're going to invade Iraq and teach
people how to be Democrats we want free
elections yeah so we encourage the
Palestinians to have a free election
they do and they elect Hamas Hamas so we
first indirectly and directly through
Israel help establish Hamas then we have
election then Hamas becomes dominant so
we have to kill him you know it it just
doesn't make sense during during the8
you can stop it right there but Pat like
what a what a point where they kind of
created to fight yaser aat but then at
the same token it's like you created a
monster I mean we did the same thing
with the Taliban in in Afghanistan he
was going to get there to perfect point
and he was just about to go there we
start like we're creating these monsters
and then we go oh my God the monster did
monster things and we're like how could
they so and go into my point Adam and I
love you to death bro it's just and I'm
getting mess just mind you on Instagram
from people Israeli people they're like
Yo dude we feel your P we understand we
want to know now when you have John
Kirby the day it happened going no no no
now's not the time to question because I
know we're talking about accountability
years down the road Adam because there's
war right now they're attacking the
ground evasion the incursion right now
is absolutely insane but it's like I'm
not one of those down the road we'll
talk about it like you talked about
George Bush Jr he belongs in in prison
and if Donald runfell I would dig his
ass up and put them in electric shair
that's how much these people killed over
a million people soldiers Americans
everybody now we're just supposed to be
like I like no just forget about it and
now you see Bush going up and talking
with Democrats like bro take your ass to
jail I hate that [__] it drives me
banana well and I hit the nail on the
head like anytime America gets involved
in regime change it's a freaking
disaster yeah Afghanistan Iraq what
they're trying to do with the PLO here
but Pat brought the biggest point to the
thing number one we need to be focused
on America who who are America allies
come second uh is it Israel or is it
Hezbollah Hamas Isis al- Qaeda Islamic
Jihad the Muslim Brotherhood is we even
talking about what are we even talking
about right here this equivocation
especially on the woke college campus
left of this you know so let me jump in
on on on this conversation because my my
views on it are are a little more
nuanced
um look what's currently happening to
Palestinian civilian first first of all
let me just get this out of the way it's
really important I was disgusted to see
anyone on the left justify or provide
cover for a terrorist group like Hamas I
was horrified by what Hamas did
absolutely Israel should go after Hamas
I have no problem with that now the way
the Israeli government and the IDF is
going after Hamas is basically
ethnically cleansing Palestinians from
the Gaza Strip okay look I'm Armenian I
see genocide when I I I can see I can
recognize genocide when I see one it is
so obvious to me like I'll give you a
few
examples if you wanted to root out Hamas
you send in Special Ops I agree okay
that is how you do it and I'm I'm not
saying that as some Lefty jao willik
said that someone who is incredibly
experienced in the military he's like
this is how you get
Hamas bombing the crap out of
residential buildings okay out of out of
that Greek Orthodox church out of the
areas where all of these innocent
Palestinian civilians are living in or
fleeing from is not the right way to go
and look that in the long term will not
keep Israel safe because what that
policy of just bombing the crap out of
that area and wiping out entire families
does is it breeds more extremism okay
first of all I think it's wrong I don't
think those civilians deserve this okay
the majority the civilians living in the
Gaza Strip weren't even born at the time
that Hamas was voted in okay most of
them half of them are under the age of
18 y right so the point that I'm trying
to make
is you there is a way of supporting
Israel which I I believe we should do
right without
justifying what they're currently doing
in the Gaza Strip right we should
provide them with the Intel they need we
should provide them with the weapons
they need with the condition that
they're going to car carry out these
operations special ops as opposed to
bombing the crap out of the Gaza Strip
killing all of these innocent civilians
from a remote location I think that's
wrong Anna with with all due respect
you're sort of falling for the
mainstream narrative that you talk about
railing against so we all saw the story
about the uh hospital that was bombed by
Israel how could you do this how could
you kill Inn innocent civilians the New
York Times didn't basically is now
retracting their statement yeah it turns
out it was the Islamic Jihad what they
failed rocket I can assure you of this
that is not definitive number one that
is not definitive number even the Wall
Street Journal but that is one example
even even if even if I give you that
argument and it is proven without a re
without any doubt that it was Hamas that
that did that that is one incident in a
situation where 1.1 million Palestinians
are being told to evacuate their homes
as they're being evacuated to the part
of the Gaza Strip where they're gonna be
safe that area gets bombed okay so let
me ask you a very direct question do you
think Israel wants to kill innocent
civilians you think Israel genuinely
wants what evidence do you have of that
the evidence is they are refusing to do
Special Operations and instead are
relying on bombing areas where they know
they know civilians are at and then
they'll turn around and say well Hamas
is using them as uh as human shield so
if someone was shooting at
you armed man grabbed a family member of
yours do you have kids no I don't oh do
you have okay your mother you talked
about your mother if an armed gunman
grabbed your mother had a gun to her
head okay and he is confronted by the
authorities by law enforcement and the
law enforcement they just decide you
know what we're not going to negotiate
we're not going to do anything we're
just going to shoot the hell out of both
of them and then they come to you and
say well your mother sorry was a human
shield would you accept that argument
that's not the question though would you
AC that argument you're making up a a
random story that what my mother has
held captive Hamas using Palestinians as
human Shields is not a justification to
indiscriminately bomb the hell out of
that region knowing full well that the
majority of people who are going to end
up dying are not Hamas militants who are
underground in the tunnels okay okay
it's the innocent civilians who are
going to lose their lives and the
flippant behavior that I see from the
West in regard to all of those innocent
people losing their lives disgusts me
okay seeing people having to leave
vacate their homes everything that
they've known being forced to leave the
land that they have that is exactly what
happened to Armenians that is exactly
what happened during the genocide and
the fact that the United States is just
willy-nilly providing cover for that
behavior absolutely disgusts me Israel
has a right to defend itself how it
defends itself is where we should have
that conversation sending special ops in
to get Hamas hell yeah go get them but
the idea that all these innocent kids
should lose their lives as a result of
this just I don't believe it I don't I I
will never support it and in the long
run that is going to make Israeli
civilians less safe not more safe it
breeds more extremism and by the way
it's dragging us into a broader War okay
you have the Arab world like ready to go
and you have Israel under the leadership
of Netanyahu acting incredibly
belligerent doing air strikes in
freaking Leb on okay talking about going
to war in Iran we're going to bring in
all of these Arab countries you think
the United States is going to stay out
of that hell no we're going to be
dragged into more forever Wars I just
think it's so destructive so stupid
we're not thinking critically and
strategically about how to help our Ally
Israel while also preventing the
reproduction of more extremism yeah the
extremism is never going to go away the
foundation of what H is going in their
founding do
their entire do is to eliminate every
Jew that lives in Israel do you
acknowledge the founding doctrine of
what Hamas is the annihilation of all ha
Hamas let me let me let me be clear so
the question is how do we annihilate
them well you can't find I need you guys
to understand nobody wants to see
innocent civilians killed including the
IDF if a government wiped out my entire
family I have nothing left to live for
and I'm real Angry okay that is a
dangerous combination and that is
exactly what is being bred right now as
we speak as entire families are getting
wiped out civilian families in the Gaza
Strip I totally get that you know the
discourse in the United States has
essentially dehumanize these people but
at the end of the day they're innocent
people in a terrible situation and they
don't deserve the absolute hell that
they're dealing with right now the death
and destruction that they're dealing
with right now I want a peaceful
two-state solution this ain't the way to
get it yeah the we are in full alignment
full agreement that we want to see Zero
civilian debts nobody wants that and I
can assure you the IDF the Mad nobody
wants civilian debts but we're we're
looking for Solutions here if I'm
standing be in front of a of a human
shield and I'm throwing missiles bombs
grenades your way and I'm trying to kill
you as a civilian and your family what
would you do if I if I'm if I'm trying
to kill you and I'm standing in front of
a civilian I'm trying to kill you Anna
what would you do hey we can't kill
civilians we need a peaceful situation
here or would you shoot back I apolog no
no what would you do no but that's you
are making a hypothetical that doesn't
exist right now we're talking about IDF
soldiers of their remote location as
they're dropping bombs that is not
what's happening right now so we're not
having a conversation about about 5,000
Rockets you me answer the question let
me what about the 5,000 rockets that
were fired on Israel that killed
civilians so what do you do there this
you say hey look until we identify where
this is coming from let question we
can't kill any c nobody wants Civ we
here's what we do here's what we do the
United States taxpayer funds the Iron
Dome that intercepts all of those
Rockets okay to pretend as though we're
talking about two equal sides is
ridiculous to me it is an asymmetrical
War so I'm happy I am so happy that the
United States did that that the United
States help fund the Iron Dome to help
keep Israel safe the point that I'm
trying to make right now is that the
current effort in basically bombing the
crap out of the Gaza Strip first of all
breaks a bunch of international laws
pertaining to war okay so there are war
crimes taking place as we speak and
we're here in the United States
pretending like we don't see it even
though every other country in the world
sees it even though the UN Security
Council sees it so aside from doing war
crimes we're also creating a future in
which Israel isn't going to be safe do
you get what I'm saying unless you think
the people of Israel know that then why
they've never had safety there can I say
how many you don't think that in 2006
when they did the disengagement they
pulled out of Gaza they weren't aware of
this no doubt this is whacka all on on
the highest proportion but at some point
if Hamas is leading Gaza that is the
government that is running Gaza and
their founding principle is the
annihilation of everybody in Israel what
choice do you have the IDF does not want
ham how do you do that how do you do
that give me an actual tangible
solution so you just do Precision while
they're shooting because on on on the 6
October 6 what, 1600 people died think a
couple number now in Palestine it's over
6,000 okay how many of Hamas have been
killed in that 6,000 do you know there's
there's 44,000 in uh Palestine how many
of them were killed and the cuz mind you
the innocent lives are at 95% how much
Hamas wins enough enough I get it Adam
Israel has to protect itself and we have
to support Israel protecting itself it
didn't protect itself that day nobody
wants to talk about it so now how many
lives is enough Hamas killed and God
rest all their souls 1,600 people that
day raped killed everything how many
more civilians have to die in Palestine
for it to be like all right we you know
we killed some Hamas but if you think
you're going to wipe out all of Hamas
that's that's not going to happen so now
what's the solution just flatten
Palestine just get everybody buy pack
your [__] and get out cuz we're bombing
everything because that's all they're
using as kids at Shields I'm pretty sure
that they do but Adam it's not
everywhere the majority of the deaths
are women and children innocent people
it's not but go deeper ven don't just
stop no again let's start with the basic
premise here that nobody wants innocent
kids and civilians to be dying nobody
the difference is when when Hamas is
literally raping and beheading children
and be and raping women okay give me a
solution other than hey don't kill
innocent civilians give me something
you're saying Precision defense
Precision forces we have when when
terrorists are embedded in schools in
hospitals and in homes how do you do
this Israel does what about roof knocks
you've got 10 minutes to get the [__]
out where they going and then they're
going to bomb where they going at at
what point does Arab the Arab countries
surrounding take accountability how many
people is is Egypt taking in how many
people is Jordan taking in how many how
many people is lebanes Israel taking in
what are you talking about you want
Israel to take
in civilians do you know how many how
many times when
when because they like to conflate Hamas
and innocent Palestinian civilians so
here's my question they're subhuman okay
how about this answer this question how
many people is the West Bank or Gaza how
many Israelis are they taking in to show
support zero in the history of their
country you want are you sure you want
to talk about the West Bank right now
hundreds thousand where they are
governed by the Palestinian Authority
which works with the Israeli government
right they are do they are not at all
governed by Hamas at the same time
Israeli government has no problem with
the settlers reigning Terror on those
people living in the West Bank right
Netanyahu has no problem with building
illegal settlements in the West Bank
okay evicting Palestinians from their
legal homes in the West Bank by the way
like what honestly answer this question
okay you have Palestinians following the
rules doing like they're governed by the
Palestinian author Authority in the West
Bank a situation that could lead to
Peaceful relations between Israelis and
Palestinians oh really all the peaceful
relations that have never existed no so
you're going on the premise that somehow
somehow in this magical world that
Anna's living in that PE is possible
zero peace is possible buing illegal
settlements in the West Bank which again
is not governed by Hamas shows the bad
faith of the current Israeli government
but it's not whether whether it's BB
Netanyahu whether it's ahood Barack good
luck trying to have peace wish that you
would just say it like it is because I
feel like you're not saying it like tell
what I'm not saying I think Israel wants
to rid that area of Palestinians period
and their activity in the Gaza Strip
right now makes it abundantly clear to
me abundantly clear listen if there's
anybody that neighborhoods entire
neighborhoods completely leveled okay by
the way you want to talk about bombing
hospitals you think that was the first
time a hospital was bombed they bomb
hospitals all the time and ask yourself
that exact hospital was bombed just like
a few days earlier okay this this
alleged hospital that was bombing
according according to according to
multiple reports according to multiple
retractions was done by Islamic Jihad
but ask yourself this question why would
they be bombing hospitals why why
because they want to see sick innocent
people die no because it continue to
remind you that's where Hamas basically
EDS so you're saying it's worth bombing
it if two Hamas guys are in a hospital
you saying it's cool to bomb the [__]
out of that thing were you getting two
Hamas asking you how many how hold on if
they're firing rockets and missiles from
that hospital hold on there was no
Rockets shot from that hospital what I'm
saying is how many amas people are just
let's say they're in there let's say
they're in there with guns you're going
to bomb the whole hospital and wipe
everybody out cancer kids with cancer to
take out let's say five or 10 Hamas
that's where Adam where she's making a
point it's special forces and let's not
pretend like they don't have some
amazing special forces in Israel and we
can support cuz we we help them as well
Adam it's like it's win is enough enough
that's what I know what she saying so
for us to wrap it up and I I love the
fiery exchange you guys are having but I
will say this to you I don't blame you
for feeling the way you do your your
your family's from Israel you're Jewish
of course you're going to have Affinity
to your community your family 100% two
uh the Ally in the Middle East is Israel
that's it we don't have as many powerful
allies as isra we have other allies but
not at the level of Israel that we have
three uh you know when you do kill 5,000
let's just say you get 40 50 100 200
let's just say you got 500 10% ofas
let's just throw that number out out of
there 40,000 the other 45,000 those
families are never going to forget it
trust me I'm I'm a byproduct where I'm
at right now at 45 years old financially
because somebody offended my dad 20
years ago in front of my face and I'm
never going to forget that I'm going to
go till I die to make sure they're going
to remember my dad's last name till the
day I die they're GNA have to so so
imagine at this small level of where I'm
going my fires come out I don't need
another $3 $400 million that's not what
what I'm doing this for I know those
people that lost family this cycle is
not going to go away it's going to take
5 10 15 maybe it's not going to happen
under netanyahu's watch matter of fact
it's not going to happen on netanyahu's
watch but it is going to happen on
another person's watch now the war you
know is this thing ever going to stop
yeah it's been going on for thousands of
years we're going to be able to stop it
now the the military side of saying
going from the the way that Jack was
talking about yes I mean they have this
underground thing that's so massive and
strategic it's freaking ridiculous
there's a video you can actually go see
it that where the guy from Fox News went
to the bottom they actually gave him a
tour of it I don't know if you seen this
or not what this looks like it's so it's
it's it's very interesting how much
underground city built by terrorists and
we're wondering how we we have to be
very careful here with these cities but
also if I were to ask the motive of
Netanyahu when I ask the pilot the
Israeli pilot you know which one I'm
talking about Vinnie when I ask him he
says honestly if you want to ask me I
don't want us to take any uh refugees
nobody I want us to be 100% Israeli Jews
that's what I want Israel to be I want
nobody else there by the way there's
nothing wrong with you believe in that
but that's who you are that's what you
believe in great go for there's some
people in America don't want anybody
else to come in here that doesn't make
it right or wrong it's their belief what
they're thinking about so where this is
going to go next again America First is
the following this is my concern this
comes back to down to the southern
border couple of these guys are like oh
you want to do that no problem Iran has
Vengeance they're just looking for an
excuse
people coming down here they're looking
for an excuse 5 10 15 years from now
we're having a regular day kind of like
the day you got a text that Kobe Bryan
died and none of us believed it kind of
like when all of a sudden 911 happened
nobody expected it we're going to have
something like that happen and then that
person's going to scream back and say
remember what you did to us 15 years ago
this is what you're getting for this so
my concern is that so if we had a
stronger president that could impose
fear on all of them collectively maybe
they would point it down a little bit
but unfortunately there's not a strong
leader in charge that can get everybody
to say relax and ton that you can be in
a room fight breaks out one person that
everybody in that room fear says guys
chill out stop not right now everybody
stops that one person is not Joe Biden
it doesn't exist in the world today
we're going to unfortunately keep having
these conflicts by the way we think
we're done with this elections gonna
happen they got 12 think about what the
Strategic the the opportunist people are
thinking about the regimes I have 12
more months to invade somebody until God
forbid somebody else gets elected
because I know I can't do it under Trump
what happened to day Reagan got elected
that day what did Iran do what Didi do
release prisoners they're likeo we'll
mess with Carter we ain't we ain't
scared of Carter we are not effing with
Trump yeah we need strong leadership
when America's strong everybody else
kind of pumps their breakes when they
want to do anything stupid anyways
appreciate the banter we got to wrap up
I got a meeting upstairs uh Anna truly a
pleasure honestly really enjoyed it I
didn't know what direction this was
going to go you're fantastic I love
listening to you I love your take as
well I appreciate you guys going back
and forth uh gang uh Anna anything that
uh uh you're working on any project that
you want the audience to follow that
maybe you're working on right now that'
be great for us to share with the
audience sure yeah definitely check us
out over at uh The Young Turks uh that's
youtube.com thee Young Turks fantastic
Rob let's put that in comment chat and
uh description and if you enjoyed what
uh uh Anna had to say you disagree let's
put the Twitter link as well so we can
also get some commentary there too gang
have a great weekend we will do this
again next week take care bye- bye
bye-bye